two hello
everybody it's Ethan Klein here at the a
Street
podcast it is
October
25th a beautiful day out here in Los
Angeles uh what can I say not a cloud in
sight actually actually that's not true
it's a little overcast yeah it's cloudy
there are clouds uh well ins sight it's
very cloudy today we have a
fantastic fantastic episode planned uh
we have no sponsors so thank you to our
members we love you members we love you
members thank you for supporting us and
thank you to everyone who's watching uh
it's all good we love it we love you God
I will say that uh when do this come out
Sam or Lena the this Teddy fresh
drop I know it comes out
and but
this November 2 week dude this drop goes
so crazy this is a a corduroy puffer the
puffer look at
this the
Pu ab's wearing one
too the puffer the
puffer wow I was dude this collection
goes
hard tons of really nice outerwear I
know Ela loves outerwear and because we
live in
LA you pretty much never ever need it
and so now that Winter's approaching I
think Ela she loves her outerwear so
there's there's really nice outerwear in
this collection I'll keep showing it off
but it's actually hot it's very warm so
I'm going to take it
off guys how's my how does my rash
look Ash yeah
better a little better better yeah Dan
is hesitant to it looks about the same
to me I I'm not I know it's it's not
it's definitely better than it was okay
I feel like it was around your whole eye
before now it feels more centered un
like the bottom right I've been more
concentrated I thought I've been putting
that ointment on and it's
certainly I don't know man I don't it
the doctor says it's supposed to it's
like antibacterial it's supposed to help
reduce inflammation but it's not
actually like treating it but apparently
with the I don't know per
periodontal dermatitis or whatever
you're supposed to not do
anything to it which is weird
because I've been dealing with this for
a long time thank you yeah that's good
it's really up here and here oh
boy this is bad but and it by the way
started to get super itchy too I'm
literally itching my eyeball look don't
do
that do do that don't do that don't do
that don't do that stop doing that hey
don't do that don't do that stop
touching your eye stop hey
it it's easy for you to say your eyeball
isn't
itch actually I have good news remember
I mentioned that my eyelids were getting
uh real itchy and dried out I put lotion
on it for a couple days and you're good
it's totally good now good for
you I'd itch the hell out of that don't
do
that well anyway thank everyone for
being here
uh we have today the culmination of many
years of research and debate yeah years
the basically we stand on the shoulder
of the Giants that come before us to
bring you this Cutting
Edge
decisive dishwasher
experiment that's right folks today is
the day we have each
brought our very own dirtiest dish
imaginable and today to we will be
determining dish vers dishwasher who
wins been a lot of debate here Dan has
been converted he says you put it in you
forget it doesn't it doesn't matter even
I mean we've seen some incredible
results caked on lentils caked on
oatmeal there are things that are just
coming off these plates that you
wouldn't
believe
um hold on I'm coming yeah Tom will be
calling in to assess the final results
and so I guess let's start by just kind
of showing off what each one of us did I
can kick it off sure why don't you or
should we do it in order of
severity uh sure um because there's a
realistic ones and then there's ones
that we said okay let's really challenge
this right so here let me pull this up
and this will kind of help me keep it
organized so some of the more normal
ones I I guess I'll start cuz mine's
fairly normal I uh got a bowl of Raisin
brand and left a bunch of chunks at the
bottom and kind of drained out the milk
and then just let it sit overnight and
did it kick up like you thought it would
huh did it get real hard yeah it's real
hard it's gunked up you know this would
take this would take a decent amount of
scrubbing to get off um I think
traditionally I probably would have
filled this bowl up to the brim and let
it sit for a couple hours and then rinse
it out and then put it in the dishwash
see it can you run your finger over it
just to see can we get a sound test it's
crunchy not going anywhere it's not
going anywhere it's it's that's good
stuck on the side right that's a good
one so um but I I would say this one is
fairly reasonable compared to some
others uh AB why don't you show yours
cuz yours is a similar
one oatmeal oatmeal hold it up let's
take a look I can't see cuz my preview
oh I'm sorry here I can take this off
for now thank you oh man you left a lot
of oatmeal in that is
caked and so is it water is it milk what
did you cook it in uh water no no no I'm
sorry milk milk milk oh milk so that's
interesting MH and we're going to leave
that out overnight is it hard or is it
still a little squishy uh still a little
squishy there's some hard pieces though
in there very good they're kind of a mix
so yeah again these are the relatively
easy ones um we also have uh I would say
Lena why don't you show yours yeah mine
is like an everyday common mess good
eggs that you'll find in any kitchen
anywhere in the country
absolutely that and how did you achieve
that beautiful caked on egg effect I
just cooked some eggs in it and I kept
them a little bit longer so that it can
burn a little bit nice no oil or
anything yes I think no no I didn't use
oil did I no I didn't I didn't use oil
yeah yeah very good that's that is a
good one I'm saying we're really going
to figure out what's going on here today
MH mhm so next up um moving to a little
bit more difficult of a category I would
say is um let's see Zach why don't you
show your mine's kind of normal the
peanut butter I I was going to say yours
and Zach's I think go ahead I'll I'll go
after you so what's going on
there wait that's not okay that doesn't
answer the question a bunch of melted
cheese ah okay so melted hardened cheese
and that's microwaved microwav to
my dude and what kind of
cheese are we featuring today uh we got
uh some chatter
some uh mozzarella wow it looks pretty
good it's can you run your finger over
it next to the mic or your nail or
something why' you do
that can't quite hear it but it looks it
looks real hard ASMR yeah that thing is
pardon cheese there's no way it's going
to clean that that's what I'm thinking
guess we'll see again uh we're really
putting it to the test here um so uh
yeah Ethan why don't you show yours okay
so mine is peanut
butter this this is
nasty oh wow this dish was on it you did
art with it it covered a whole
thing I was like you know let's do it
and then so this is the realistic one
and then now I went uh you know oh I I
covered the back of the wooden spoon
with peanut butter as well the back is
peanut butter the front is Theodore's
slime oh which is actually keying out
uh the Slime is a there's a phenomenon
these kids they love the slime and it
seems all good and fun go keys off if
you want to show that again once it once
it falls mhm or spills that turns
into like the most disastrous hard to
clean Nightmare and so I took a slime
and I smudged it right into the
crevasses there hell yeah Kass and I
also have a plate here with a medy of
slimes this is more the green slime this
is more kind of a brown slime different
textures different peanut butter that's
slime as well this is all slime got it
yeah okay sweet very curious to see how
the Slime does I need to wash my ha um
cam why don't you show yours this is
getting into the little bit uh more
ridiculous mode here all right I uh put
some paint on a plate and what kind of
paint uh it's acrylic paint that I got
from Blick art supplies I think that
one's going to wash uh it might but
there's there's a thickness to it it
doesn't really read on camera it's like
there's a texture here here I suspect it
will do better than you'd think with
that uh being a water-based paint um but
I wouldn't be surprised if there's some
some flakes hanging on there yeah I
think I don't think it'll I think it'll
get it but not perfectly um can I share
a secret with you guys and potentially a
million viers at home be quiet this this
is the secret between you and I keep it
cool this is this is my roommate's
plate I don't have any
plates I'm telling you snitching dude
what the man snitching now she's
going to come for me she's going to say
I'm liable experiment H me up for a dis
I'll see you on Reddit cam M I'm going
to talk to HR about this I used to pan
from the office because I didn't want to
ruin one of ours that's fair that's
actually Fair that's
fair I don't blame you for
that um why don't we show uh Ian
next okay uh I cooked uh a pack of bacon
ooh got it all greased up and then I put
it in the freezer ooh froze the bacon
grease this is ice cold pan right here
that one I think I'm just going to say
it I think that one's going to wash cuz
once it get that all is just going to
melt right out I think so too Perhaps
Perhaps I guess we'll see it's just
there's a lot going to have be happening
in that washing machine I I you seem to
have a lot of faith have may perhaps
I've actually gotten through to you a
little bit well I'm just thinking about
how temperature is going to affect these
cuz I know it gets real hot yep in there
yep yep which is going to affect a lot
of the oils and stuff are we going to be
able to check on the drain of the
dishwasher well so not the drain
necessarily but there is a removable
filter which right now I checked is
completely clean okay so and we can when
we go load it up I'll even I'll pull it
out for a second we can demonstrate very
good just uh full transparency very good
and then we'll check it at the end and
we'll see how well it did very very good
um so now uh Sam do you want to show
yours wait Sam yes oh yeah okay okay I
did grits nice
M up pan if y'all have ever made
grits before that turns into
concrete if you leave it in there and I
like that one Sam cuz it's a deep pan so
it's going to be you know a little more
challenging for the water to get right
in there mhm very good all right and
uh uh oh wait this isn't the last okay
the pen ultimate one Olivia do you want
to show yours this one's pretty
this one is um corn syrup and um sugar
sugar sugar the uh spatula seems to be
uh stuck the Whisk has made a friend
with the with the little pot it's
basically just glue the pot full
of glue I think that one's going to wash
you think so because again the
temperature just the boiling point but I
feel like you have to get it pretty hot
to uh to turn it into that right it yeah
it has to get to 300 in order to get to
hardening point no but it doesn't need
to be 300 to melt it to soften it enough
to wash Olivia has found herself in hot
possibly soon to be boiling water
literally we'll see but that's a great
one I love that one very good and then
finally last but certainly not least is
by far the most up one uh love
has created a wild card plate here that
I honestly think might break the
dishwasher yes let's take a look we
might need an appliance repair man hey
interesting it's not catching up very
well on the camera but here as I
promised yesterday or Monday toothpaste
mhm uh hot glue hot glue now hot glue
you mean like from a glue gun or yeah g
well that yeah that's going to break our
dishwasher yeah yeah yeah that's not
even the worst this is uh this I think
this has to be I think this is rubber
cement okay that's good that'll be good
for the dra this is uh what the this is
Gorilla Glue this is you know what the
worst possible outcome of this is that
like the whole sewage line from the
building to the Sewer needs to be dug up
that would be bad but this is very small
amount it's a small amount it's a small
it's a very small amount and this is uh
Dy wall spackling like spackle you know
if you have a hole dude what the I
think the the filter would prevent most
of us from going we got some
lipstick okay lipstick and what's the
black lipstick the black is taped right
so that he could kind of uh and do we
expect the tape to come off what's the
expectation there I don't think so this
is good ass tape that that gorilla
electric
type this is we're going to break the
I think it's going tobly now here's the
here's the some issues we have tons of
photos of people submitting we have uh
we have empirical evidence from Dan so
let me show you it's clear
that the dishwasher is much better at
washing things than we anticipated here
are some of the results a rice caked
wooden
spoon oh I just click over here wait
where's the result wait yeah
this part one we need part
two but this one is dis oh this one also
is missing part
one am I am I interpr maybe try
refreshing it
okay it's got the arrow but I think it's
just the photo of the arrow yeah it is
it's a screenshot from
Reddit it might be out of order or
something yeah see there you go sorry oh
it's out of order so here's the wooden
spoon before CED and rice here it is
afterwards spotless I've had that do do
that to me before where it doesn't save
that and then here is uh let's see let
me find the pan oh my God what is that
is it like beans it looks like
they oh no macaroni oh oh yeah they
got the Hazmat gloves on dude what it
clean crazy right if it can clean that I
think it's got a pretty good shot at a
lot of these that we put clean that
that's nuts
man so it seems like here it goes all
about 24 hours dried on only the knife
came out dirty this person said wash
cycle was 2 and a half uh 2 hours 30
minutes pancake batter even washed out
she said I think it's a Woman based on
the uh the toe however I won't make
assumptions uh about the gender at all
who knows I want to talk about feet
Zach's toes wait are your toes painted
or just your hands my fingernails
okay
um here is the pan what the
what is that is that that seems
similar to what you've done uh Olivia is
it sugar is it yeah grits potato mesh M
yeah yeah something like that so that
one was really up and I
believe that that the result of it is up
here clean yeah there you go
spotless wow so from preliminary
results from you guys at home thank you
for sharing this thing is really good so
we came here not doing the easy stuff we
know those will wash we're here to
challenge the dishwasher we're here to
challenge the thesis that no preting
pre-washing is necessary
ever and today we will be uh putting
that to the test so uh who's going to
liaz on these dishes I am Dan and Sam
are grabbing all the dishes okay so we
are going to be grabbing the
dishes we will be placing them in the
dishwasher and setting a wash to go for
the whole show the whole
[Applause]
show the dishwasher goes for 2 and 1/2
hours that's how is that energy
efficient no way they say it is though
they say the dishwasher is way more
efficient than hand washing go I don't
really well fact check that AB I feel
like
that according to um WHL pool it says
that most dishwasher Cycles can last
anywhere between 1.5 to 4 hours 4 hours
I Pro that's probably like standard
grade like restaurant Type S no the
restaurant one is short we learned from
really it should it should be long I
can't tell if that's a bad dishwasher or
a good one cuz if it's got to wash that
long are dishwashers more efficient I
think they're they are supposed to be
way more efficient on water and energy
using a dishwasher is more efficient
than handwashing as it saves more water
and
electricity how is that possible a 2 and
a half 4our wash do we
kiding but I've I've heard that time and
time again the technology just keeps
getting better and better so I believe
it I guess
they I understand if they use the same
water for 2 and a half hours the same
water back back at home me and my dad
didn't have a dishwasher and we filled
up the sink with water yeah like you
plug it so you reuse the water too you
don't have like running constant they
don't use that much that's surprising
dude and so the energy thing is
what has me questioning though how can
you run an appliance for four hours and
it's
not all right they're they're ready in
the
kitchen here it says uh using dishwasher
can help reduce the amount of water use
as well as less energy that's needed to
heat up the
water damn go ahead Dan let's start
let's start packing it up can you hear
me over there yeah we can hear you okay
cool all right so we're going to start
loading up this bad boy here um the
peanut butter we're actually a little
concerned about space here but so here
we
have going in we have the cheese from
Zach here and they're going to goad and
load the uh bacon grease there there it
is bacon grease and and it doesn't
matter you know we're packing this up
uh in a in a in the correct way we're
not
overpacking it build that overload it
okay
here's the Grits okay so I'm mostly
concerned about that in this one getting
in here in a reasonable
way how is the pan supposed to be
entered into that I guess just like that
yeah that seems
good seems good move this one so it's
not we are playing petris a little bit
here with the dishes we want to give
everything a fair chance so that there's
no disputing it after the fact none you
can throw that just face down in there
which one is that Sam we have that was
the raisin brand raisin brand we got the
spatula very
good God damn it Ethan much peanut
butter what's on your hand there uh
whoever's recording
AB here why don't we do this one right
here that's the
Slime Theodore if you're watching I'm
sorry just took a little bit I went in
Theodore's room when he was sleeping and
stole his slime just a little bit though
Theodore I promise yeah here's the
peanut butter
one this all looks like totally legit
the placement is
clean one more coming in this is loves
what about putting it on
the
okay so Dan is having some
top row is fine we're going to go to the
top row wait hold on should we you want
to remove those
dishes like the real
dishes the these are dirty I don't know
if it'll affect things we take it out as
a variable it shouldn't it shouldn't
affect it all right we'll take them out
we'll take them out no well also I don't
want them to be
like covered in toxic right concrete our
gles right it probably will make that
not great okay out you know for the
welfare of so here we go we're putting
in the last one
here all right this is big this is
big oh and here before we go want to
demonstrate here is
the wow spotless I mean there's a
there's a little speck of something
there but not a big deal okay that
oatmeal's not going to even fit that
thing that's where all the food
collects so you got to you're supposed
to empty that thing out occasionally cuz
that's
disgusting you know that thing's going
to be vile for
sure all right all right so here's the
important thing Dan uh he's explain what
you're doing
Dan yeah so uh I've gone ahead and I've
puted up this gel here um I think it's
important to point out what sh using uh
we requested the most generic one so
that you know we couldn't be accused of
using some like high power ultra scrub
so this is just a Kroger brand standard
dish gel Kroger's finest man Kroger's
finest I bet that bottle was like 22.99
right yeah that's what I've gone ahead
and I've loaded the uh main wash basin
here uh up to the fill line now I'm
going to demonstrate right here we have
the uh
pre-wash so the pre-wash right in there
and load a decent amount in there too
okay okay fantastic and we're just going
to seal this up detergent see it says it
right there seal it put a nice little
click we know that we're in place we're
locked in ready to go what's that next
to it Rinse
Aid so the rinse a is uh deceptively
named I was confused by that too but
apparently the rinse aid is for the
final stage of the cycle um where it
rinses it and then dries it it helps
break up the water tension so the water
comes off it basically you know how
sometimes you get spots water spots on
your dishes that can assist in that it's
not really relevant to this test fair
enough ah the final solution wait what
all right and uh I guess it's hard to
see here because of this lip but to
demonstrate we're going to describe the
cycle describe the time the
settings
cycle 2 hours
45 we're to put it
normal 24 which is 2 hours 55 minutes
we're not going to get the results of
this until the very end of the show
today
so you all know although we could pull
it earlier because it'll just no no no
no we couldn't that wouldn't um heated
dry everything else seems standard here
all right unless you have any objections
I'm going to fire this up n everything
there looks straight up perfect for our
experiment fantastic here we
go and so the great experiment begins
we're going to flip this sorry we're
dirty H so come on in we're clean and
now we wait and this is very exciting
guys I don't think anybody to date has
done this thorough of a testing of this
hypothesis here live nobody uh-uh so
you're going to want to stay
tuned till the all the way to the end
for this one stay tuned there are going
to be surprises and thrills
throughout well thank you everybody I'm
very excited here today to let's go
let's let's go I think I think there's
going to be a lot of surprises in there
you know I'm nervous man I think I'm
nervous I'm you good about it or no I
don't know man oh no I'm definitely
leaning more towards the no Preen side
but we've we're I'm saying there's going
to be some surprises so there it
is very good so
exciting there was a huge
controversy after Monday's episode ton
of people were mad at me saying they're
disappointed they don't want to watch
the show anymore the reason for that as
everybody was watching knew knows is
that love was asking for Boba and I
didn't
acknowledge him I didn't know you were
asking for Boba when did this Boba
conversation take place um it happened
when you were at the bathroom but well
then how you
me when you sat down you sat quiet and I
asked can we buy some BBA Boba boa boba
did you say or Boba B he said B he's
trying out boa today I didn't hear you I
said can we have some boba what am I
your dad buy your buy some boba
after school snack yeah it's just a
suggestion like a group I would love a
groupa so yes so so yes I think that we
should order today but do you guys want
food or Boba oh I I want Boba what do
you got there love uh some uh Champions
Curry
well we should really ask Cameron good
morning Curry what Cameron do you want
food or Boba there's a first time for
everything Jesus Christ
um damn there's a lot of pressure riding
on this I'm I'm I'm going to go B I'm
going to go B boba boba boba boba it was
a trick question anyways baa you want
Boba you guys really want Boba I I'd be
down for food too feeling like Boba
person I do
bobaa you only want Boba cuz you already
got food for yourself true that's what
I'm saying that's why I'm asking the
other yeah I ate before we do a live
show where we talk
yeah what's about to
do goddamn R
whatever I'm here for 10 4 hours a day
you
10 10 4 I'm up grinding from 1: to 4:30
p.m. every single day that's what people
don't understand about by every day I
mean three or four times a week uh
so we'll order Boba then let's go we can
do both I guess I mean b and is place
that has boba that has
food I just don't like boba's just so
lame I'm so out B what about it's lame
what do think lame I've been over this
but it's like it's so first of all so
many calories and all of them are so
rich for no no so sweet for no damn
reason I love that about Boba personally
you like Prime which is like an assault
on the taste buds you can get like 25%
sweetness though I do that every and
it's like choose your own Boba Adventure
I have never got a boba I like it hasn't
happened yet you choose the most
disgusting you got honey can I order for
you no the Honeydew one was yeah that
wasn't good crazy can I order a boba for
you yeah just tell me what it is first
how about I don't how about I just you
go in blank because I listen I'm very
calorie conscious right now and I don't
going to be getting 1,000 calor I'll get
a very low calorie option for you tell
me the calorie
amount okay you know what I mean right
me even 300 you guys got to understand
when I'm pushing I keep finding more
peanut butter on my hands 300 I CED that
it's under my finger nails I CED
that I'll tell you you know even
cuz I'm pushing like 1,500 calories Max
so when you're looking down the face of
a 300 calorie drink that's taken a lot
away from you in a day you never have a
sweet treat I do but like having a you
know what I mean having a chocolate is
like probably 50 calories but having a
boba is like super like a really fun
experience it's like
different you know it's just a sweet
treat I'm with you Ethan I stand with
you no thank you cuz Ian you're on that
grind too right yeah you're trying to
bulk up I'm not into it I don't like the
Boba thank you ancy we agree on
something I like the brown sugar boba I
like
the I like a lot of them I think I like
all of them the preview Frozen Love Is
oh he's back um so Ian do you want food
is that what you're saying I would like
some real food yeah like what what is
real food tapioka
pearls like a freaking piece of chicken
or something you know okay I'm sure
there's lots of people that can do that
that'd be pretty crazy
right are you okay could certainly make
that happen
he is God's silly as
goose so let's get some chicken going
for eating
chicken you know and Zach your thoughts
on the Boba vers chicken debate I'll
take the chicken m Bubba is just it's so
many extra calories you just don't need
thank you yeah it's not worth it live a
little dude you haven't drank in a twink
bro you don't understand
months live a little you don't
understand what it is like to be me I'm
not a twink I'm an otter thank you if I
have a boba beautiful otter you're a
beautiful twink and we love that about
you I'm an otter although you're hairy
do twinks need to be hairless that's why
I'm an otter you know g a beautiful cute
little sea otter yep on your back
breaking open a clam and drinking Boba
what fisting that's why they eat they're
very cute daughters I don't disagree
with that you know they hold hands when
they when they're like
floating they're so forget it forget it
so so hold on those in favor of chicken
say I and put your hand in the air you
okay hold on what happened just now what
happened I see Four Hands raised am I
missing anyone else AB where's your hand
Lena well if if my friends want to eat
they should eat I take Boba tomorrow
well it's a it's kind of a dead heat
right now AB you're Boba yeah I'm Boba
me L's probably Boba too you guys
probably okay so there's only four for
chicken so that's actually a blowout for
Boba
huh huh
huh it's just I don't know huh we can do
both I don't like drinks that make you
full that's the thing though it doesn't
make me full even I'm still hungry well
I also like hate smoothies for that you
and me were different girls I just don't
I don't know I'm just a girls girl I
support all you guys God worked extra
hard with Blended drinks yeah I feel can
can they up a chicken can you find a
boba spot that also does food or is that
possible like maybe L Tha places yeah
thae places yeah thae places will have
it that's true Is that real food Ian
yeah that counts yeah yeah yeah okay cuz
I wonder if the best Boba spots are not
going to be making food they're going to
be focused on the Boba itself yeah
generally yeah but you can't really
Boba up Lena are you Boba or you
food Boba
always all right let's go the phenomenon
the Boba phenomenon is here uh taking
the World by storm we can order from two
different spots you know we've all been
through so much let's treat ourselves
it's been a long long week this
conversation started with you trying to
make
up something to love I mean we'll do
both we're we're getting both that's F
that's we have been through a lot both
both
shame to celebrate our dishwasher
Extravaganza I think about it like this
I haven't drank boba in 3 months I do um
three months and then I the days divided
on the calories and that's like one
calorie a day dude one I'm curious if
it'll help you love no no it won't
all right let's move on well we'll get
those orders together great now you guys
know I've been very interested in the
Jade stone operations that are taking
place in the beautiful uh province of
yunin China it's going to be taking
place in a much closer Province uh I
love Union I have a fantasy of settling
there with my family and retirement and
just becoming a MH a Jal Jade Trader MH
but until then I enjoy from afar
actually we have the Jade uh expert
coming in next week is that right Dan a
week from today a loyal foa Trooper who
happens to be uh very deep in the world
of gemstones and minerals and all sorts
of rocks various types uh she contacted
us the other day uh through a Super Chat
got a hold of me I talked to her
yesterday she's going to bring in a
whole bunch of rocks uh some of them
will Jade some of them will be uh what
was it NE nephite nephite is good uh
well some will be nefrite some will be
jadeite and some will be various other
green tinged gemstones hold on but you
won't know which one but hold on I
thought real nephite was
expensive uh nephite was the slightly
more common version of no I think that
was the more valuable one I don't think
so I think jadeite is the really is
that's the if you're going to question
my credentials on this um she got
shungite Maybe I'm Wrong versus NE uh we
can she does she have shungite we'll
check on that Zach that's the one that
blocked five G right yeah I'm feeling a
little off I need some shate but anyway
she she'll be coming in with a bunch of
rocks we will be selecting rocks
everybody on the crew and she is also
bringing a rock saw and she is going to
cut them open so exciting and we're
going to see how we did so exciting um
do we possibly have oh AB said J not
what talking show your Source no it's
not he responds in the
Discord show your s both materials are
extremely tough and resistant to wear
though is somewhat
tougher yeah you want you want soft
dude I like my tough however the
top color for Jade Imperial green only
occurs in jadeite additionally jadeite
is more likely to be translucent these
factors in combination with greater
Rarity make jedite more expensive than
nephrite okay fine there you go there
you
go yeah I want to show what's your
Source because here's our internal
Discord that we use to communicate on
the show Ethan actually typed out no
it's
not I wanted to get I said erase that
and retype it it's so
funny um but anyway that's all very
exciting but there's something else
happening in the world that I think
needs our
attention um here oh this is really
gorgeous oh wow so this is
jadeite can we have the lady make one of
those that's powerful I don't know how
Adept she is at sculp I think she's more
into the collecting so for the record
the people I follow they they using
laser Engravings to cut it oh cool so I
don't know if we have access to one of
those or maybe we have like a rock
polishing kind of machine she can bring
in I can ask about that I don't know if
she'll have a laser carving tool uh
that'd be sick if she did though someone
and then we can all carve she's probably
watching right now so uh if you are
emerald let me uh let me know her name
is Emerald by the way which U her name
is Emerald yeah dude no way well she
goes by Emerald she changed her name to
Emerald perhaps which is dope mhm I
changed my name to
podcast so people know but anyway my new
obsession is the metal ball
rolling uh videos that you see on Tik
Tok I love these it's
fascinating and I don't quite know where
it's taking place it seems to me to be
like if I had guess I found I found out
the whole St about this so if I had to
guess and then you can tell me if I'm
right okay
um I mean it looks like India or
Pakistan or something I I don't know
something in that area you are in the
ballpark for sure especially with that
second
guess oh okay um it is in Pakistan
though okay nice no isn't it is not okay
great I was right no not what is it what
is it uh it's a
Bangladesh okay we love them which uh
used to be part of Pakistan so it's
definitely in that region so here's what
they do they bring out all the folks
from the community and they play these
kind of uh skill slash luck games and
then what they win is like the most
common household items it
really it really is very interesting to
see like they they'll win like
bottle of vegetable oil or like a bucket
like just a bucket edible oil so here
here it
is and so she's putting the metal
beautiful Chrome
balls beautiful they're racing down the
track everyone's cheering for her lots
of
excitement now here you can see the
holes have different prizes so boom she
hit a bucket boom she hit onion getting
a little getting a jam there what does
that one say oh that that one's a Miss
oh almost got that garlic that one is a
2 kilos of rice fragrant rice actually
beautifully smelling
rice and
so that is
the that's the
onions That's The Fragrant rice and then
here comes the bucket very
ni and here comes the bucket first of
all the I don't know
clearly uh these people are living in a
different resource uh valued their
resource uh their perception of
resources is different than ours and I
do think it's interesting to
look at these look at this and be like
damn bro look how stoked they are just
to win some oil like come on guys get it
together
there speak for yourself this how many
how many many buckets do you have you
lucky imperialist
pig you know what I mean so appreciate
what you have but the good people at
Bangladesh are are are beautiful FK
people I'd love to donate to these games
if I can because I feel like I could
make a big difference like maybe I'll
just donate a car and it'll just
everything
up just
totally yeah Mr B should go here and
just ruin them all ruin the economy yeah
give them iPhones
so here let's see how she does uh once
again beautiful Chrome balls are racing
down the track she's placing them
delicately uh
skillfully down the red track and here
they come hitting the Pango I believe
it's called the Pango
board Pango I don't there's a game where
like on Price is Right that's a Miss
edible oil garlic oh oh got that garlic
garlic and then
ooh g g what's edible oil isn't I mean I
think it's just a a cooking oil it's
just another
term and I mean listen that's a fat
that's a whole lot of oil that's a lot
of oil so congratulations to her and
what was the other thing she
won ah she won garlic garlic yeah yeah
let me see how much garlic she
got she garlic exactly thank you
so let's take a look
here oh that's a that's a whole
yeah that's a they're hooking it up so
here we go beautiful Chrome balls which
one do you guys think you would want to
win from this board if you had to
choose I myself personally am a bucket
man
myself I like the fra fragrant rice
fragrant rice sounds beautiful two kilos
of fragrant rice that's a lot that's a
lot of rice so am I to assume the
outside one ones are more valuable cuz
they seem rare and harder to hit oh oh
oh so close edible oil onion lentils oh
fantastic so there's a nice little look
like two kilos of orange lentils that's
a lot of garlic man this is beautiful
and none of them are happy by the way
when they get their prize nobody
Smiles which makes me think like
um let's get some more oil out there
make put some Smiles on their face I
don't
know I'm such like a white colonist
sounding yeah I don't know it
might be a cultural thing maybe they you
know is to stay humble you just two
kilos of
lentils I don't know I
can't actually if there is a way to
donate I really do seriously want to
donate though uh it's not really like
that um if you want to read this little
write up
let me let me enjoy actually I'll play
the video and you we can all enjoy it
and I'll read too okay but here come the
beautiful Chrome balls racing down the
red track skillfully gracefully added
put your balls in my mouth those would
not fit in your mouth Dan I'm afraid
they're quite
large but here they come we are
getting ooh bucket to give me a bucket
yo give me
a y onion lentils oh no got this is a
fat load
though holy
so let's see
lentil
garlic look at that look at that stool
man and a
bucket God damn the crowd is going crazy
dude she going to stand on that stool
she's going to height is
required
here it is I'll I'll read the
description
um they're huge on Facebook apparently
and YouTube so this is a big
organization we'll look into it but Omar
Sunny somat the creative mind behind the
SS food challenge has garnered
significant attention by organizations
engaging game challenges in
Bangladesh the games are not just for
entertainment but they also provide
essential items as prizes for the
winners thus aiding individuals in need
while creating a sense of community that
is
beautiful what a
nice what a nice beautiful thing I
wonder how he's funding it though if
it's you know what I mean
cuz I think from the revenue from his
channel and his Facebook page which is
huge oh so I wonder if what was the he's
he's like Bangladesh Mr Beast but
instead of like torturing people for
$500,000 he's is like giving away food
well hold on though is he really that
big in
Bangladesh uh yes yeah because if that's
true then I'm saying I'm thinking like
these buckets though are not that
significant for someone who's getting
like a billion views I don't think he's
getting a billion views H my eyes is
itchy as dude I definitely
think he has profit margins big ones
what was his what was it in the
beginning how you know this was this guy
just so he originally started with doing
food eating
challenges uh were you know like eating
contests or whatever but then it over
time he has evolved it into all these
various games and you know it's not just
this ball rolling he's got a he's got a
whole like prices right set with like a
million oh look at the ball motion on
that one very
good let's see onion fragrant rice
edible oil it doesn't stop oh bucket
bucket oh man
so uh let's continue this guy Omar began
his YouTube channel in 2016 focused
mainly on comedic content he later
initiated uh a singing Talent
competition as he journeyed across
Bangladesh scouting for singers however
in 2019 an idea struck him to start a
food eating challenge to entertain and
engage the laborers in villages who are
often bored and tired after a day's work
this idea later morphed into game
challenges with the co 19 pandemic
started and people including children
were spending more time on their phones
interesting what is that one milk powder
see I haven't seen anyone win that one
yet that's a rare
one milk
powder is that just like that's just
like evaporated milk like what do we do
with milk powder how you how you going
to milk do we put it in tea you use it
all kind of things yeah what is it oh is
that the bag on top
and he puts it in there's a
yeah put it in the
bucket
um how many views does this
have it has it doesn't say how odd is
this his thing SS
food yeah it is yeah yeah so here you
can see his views are pretty good here
on Tik Tok 10 million oh this one looks
exciting oh yeah let's do the 10 million
one so here we go
o ooh o sugar oh nailed it it's a bouncy
ball oh this is nice you can't lose oh
she lost say so she did lose if it comes
back past the red line you lose tool
what's tool I love that I love how
objective that is it's open-ended random
tool what's the tool uh tickets
lateralis you're right on sugar new
dress lentils oh she's cleaning
up oh oh
is that double sugar I feel like that
count as double sugar no it's not she
won new dress tool L I got to know
what's the
tool I don't think they're going to show
it in this one no he oh they do so
here's the
okay oh a bag is the bag part of the
prize or is that for
everybody stool it's a stool wait
is oh the stool's the tool you think so
yeah I didn't see a tool unless a bag's
a tool I think you might be right is a
bag a tool yeah I think it's the stool
excellent this is fun this is
great o tool so let's see if she get if
she gets the St hold on hold on Oh I
thought she was on her way to perfect
clear if she perfect clear she gets a
new Tesla Model
[Music]
S here we go get that flower oh so close
she own edible oil sugar lentils and
sting operation the games which are
physical and Innovative in nature are
designed by dedicated team under Som
rat's supervision so this guy has a
whole operation happening par
participants in the games are selected
on a first come first serve basis and
compete for prizes like soybean oil rice
and other daily
Essentials oh wait hold on we're we're
doing both no
Sam
uh some people want Bob bed some people
don't
so the people who want food are going to
get food and not Boba oh so we're going
to do two separate orders yes we're
splitting apart a nation divided cannot
stand you guys know that
right well Dan get me a boba get me the
Boba of you're
choosing okay and then Sam can you tell
send me the spot you guys are ordering
from yes I will thank you new
um the initiative has grown popular
especially among villagers and those
from less affluent backgrounds with
Games held in over 40 villages in the
pabna district the games are recorded
and posted on social media platforms and
the videos have accumulated over a
billion views let's go the initiative is
self-funded through monetization on
YouTube and Facebook allowing for the
purchase of prizes the aim is not only
to entertain but also to provide
essential items to Winners thereby
addressing some of the challenges posed
by inflation is the Bangladesh economy
going through stuff right know I I don't
know anything about
it yo she's about to clear it
yo let go that's so sweet she
getting a hug from her her daughter oh
she told her to off though wait
what happened she really it's time for
prizes hold on I thought that was sweet
but she really said off to to that
girl oh I went back too far can we
get a playby playay on that the hug hold
on okay so it's very exciting here comes
the girl she's happy she says I love you
mommy she goes she goes out of here
dude look at
that she just gets everything the rice
the sugar the lentils the oil the bucket
the
bag the stool oh man
congratulations that's that is big
that's a big win oh it is her
daughter
um let's see yeah what's the deal with
the Bangladesh economy are they going
through hard times what is I don't know
well Google it what the hell they said I
think it's a relatively poor country yes
well they said they're going through
inflation problems which may be you know
after Co 19 are they what kind of
inflation are they looking at uh let's
see you want the rate yeah cuz I know
some places like in most places
inflation is really high right now it's
a problem but in other places it's like
univa
high uh 9% in
June
um 9% in June I mean that's on kind of
on par with what you're seeing around
the world yeah which is uh
unfortunate but uh okay here is
um this one looks really
exciting we got this twist we got the
swivel we're kicking it Oh I thought it
was coming out but no not yet
ooh
okay
okay yo sugar wait what's with the
reaction shot in the LI bottom left you
see this like yeah it's on multiple
videos we noticed that yesterday wait
what and slowmo of I think it might
be is it their equivalent of uh kinetic
sand just some random woman slow motion
put putting her hair
back what the it's super
weird this is the original too this
isn't like bootleg well here let's watch
let's watch like this cuz I think maybe
this is the intended viewing I don't
know
this is
bizarre
okay lentils fragrant
rice two fragrant rice
whoa Kil fragrant rice and two Kil
lentil can you um Can somebody look up
what is fragrant rice
exactly you know I'm not sure that I
know what it is oh here's a new girl in
slow motion uh that we've got down
here
um she is also oh she's spatti rice
how's that fragrant though isn't it just
long like long stem or whatever they
call
it
[Music]
[Applause]
okay R so on Facebook if you go
[Music]
here uh here it says fragrant rice is
generally white rice which is not
jasmine rice only with similar Aroma to
Jasmine rice most of which are H pathum
rice or pathum one rice which are
developed strange to have a similar
taste to Jasmine rice fragrant rice is
the rice that can be grown all year
round and that's thank you by the way to
genetically modified foods which is
literally saving the lives of hundreds
of millions of people around the world
fortified with vitamins and super right
that can grow year round all you morons
walking around Farmers Market looking
for organic carrots or whatever the
you care about just know
that it doesn't matter a car you go for
the GMO go for the GMO it's
better science up you know what I
mean I don't believe there's any
evidence that GMO foods cause causes any
adverse well it does cause adverse
effects to some environments but in
terms of like health I don't believe
that there's any evidence at all that
suggests that it's adverse to
health um also I should tell you organic
food also uses a as pesticides some
people think that they don't on organic
food but that's not true
either um they all
do and the and I and it's the pesticides
they're not going to be harmful either
they're going to wash
off and uh any Trace amount left is
probably
harmless but it's on both of them so
save their
money go with the
science goes with the fragrant
rice I'll choose fragrant rice
anytime you sure we don't have sponsors
today sounds like sponsor by fragrant
rice fragrant rice brought to you
by the genetically modified food is
Association for
America let's check their Facebook page
oh let's check their YouTube channel
page I want to see what their views are
like
here so go to 1.7 million
nice so this one has 12 million 6
million let's see what their latest ones
are looking
like not crazy
frankly some have only 15 20 this one
has 30 3 300,000 I wonder
what determines how successful they are
or not cuz some of them are just not
doing that well like here this one has
22,000 let's take a
look is it just or maybe this one's just
not a fun game and people are
losing like I'd hate to see someone win
nothing I think we might be about to see
that yo see this is why people aren't
[Music]
watching oh okay all right
congratulations edible Oil we're playing
a pool game oh slick shots brother we
got a pool
shark okay I wonder why this one is
getting getting
heat but if we jump over to the Facebook
page this is where it's really happening
I as I understand
it
um could someone fact check me on the or
organic food has no adverse effects
claim wait this is this is Facebook they
just ripped off the Tik Tok
interface I haven't been on Facebook in
years that's what the it totally
ripped off their interface thing yeah I
mean so did Instagram right oh it's just
reals they just called reals yeah oh
it's the same
thing same similar thing it's like their
version of it YouTube too I think you
can cross post between in Facebook cuz
it's all zucked right you can let's take
a look though this one has 1.8 million
views yo this is a good one yeah this
one's really cool this seems very hard
to set up cuz if that wheel goes on the
side right GG's they should do more of
this one so what do you get if you knock
them cuz this one seems hard you better
get something big a
Tesla if oh
oh new person new Challenger
dude oh man oh this is the one this is
the one no we got to try some of these
out can we do these I want to win some
rice is it just looping we already
watching no no no it's not looping oh
it's not okay yo I thought it hit the
hit the side this it y you get wait what
I'm dying to know what he gets oh they
don't show the reward did you show it
Ian no thank you I don't know why it
opens there go
[Music]
ahead what did he
get
uh so wait is it it's not looping this
is a really long
[Music]
reel do we know what he got know any
see whoa oh that one's cool let's go
right now dude that that is honestly a
great carnival
game
wow come on baby show me
oil show me fragrant
rice oh next next contestant show me
bench show me
St and nobody's winning it's
heartbreaking
[Music]
you got this
brother oh come on
man this is a tough game this is not
easy
nice so anyway that's my boy who I've
become a big fan of
actually
um his name once again for everybody
who's interested
he is the world world famous Omar Sunny
somrat fantastic absolutely great so
there it is Bangladesh it's all
happening can we set up a game like that
I mean I guess he Mr Beast is doing that
for America but like in a way more
do you think what Mr Beast does
is more cynical than what somat
does it's hard I've thought about a lot
cuz they're giving free stuff to people
but they're using them you talking about
Beast or so or both both I guess
yeah well I I am curious how much money
he's making if he is making any
money you know what I mean this one has
13 million on Facebook holy
smokes
13 I do like how creative he gets with
the games a lot of this stuff I've never
seen before
dang that's so
[Music]
[Applause]
close yeah it's hard to say I mean in a
sense I
think I want to say what Beast does is
more cynical
but I mean the man locked two brokies in
a he's like I just locked in Two Broke
idiots in a room to see how long they
can survive before they knife each other
so I don't know seems less serious these
ones the world yo this is
crazy
oh he's pretty good he hasn't hit the
barrier
yet feel like I could do this one no
problem you think so
I think
so so anyway there that is
um we got to look in can I donate I want
more games I want more games I want
bigger
prizes you know like I said I want to
absolutely destroy the local
economy basically when someone wins they
become like the uh the aristocra of the
village forever generational wealth
right that'd be way way funnier
$100,000 million
dollars thank you to uh
Omar very interesting stuff what do you
guys make of all this do we love it do
we hate it do we think it's
okay not
sure moving
on
uh okay the eel pit we've got the tick
tocker harassing Scientologist we've
got cheating culture in Japan we did
excuse
me um let's do the this guy who harasses
Scientologist I find this quite
interesting this guy's Tik Tok account
name is streets
La he goes to Scientology locations on
Hollywood Boulevard and confronts them
there's a big
Scientology uh Center in
LA to uh um pass it every day when I was
going to school down there yeah and they
would just harass the out of me
they would yeah like in what way like
just like keep approaching and say oh
I'm good and then they keep prying and
so on and so forth oh they're trying to
get you to join correct and I I would
have to pass it every day and it would
just creep the out of me so were
they just they were this is the building
by the way if you want to know how
creepy and weird it is who the
builds a church like this have you ever
walked down that street I've never
walked by it no it is so Eerie down that
Street dude it's like you know
every other Street around it is like
trashed out and everything but then it's
pristine there they have all these
people looking at you while you're there
all in the same uniform it's creepy they
um wait are you talking about the one on
Hol Boulevard are you talking about the
uh wherever elron hubard way is I think
that's that same one right that's no no
no I used to pass is on Hollywood
Boulevard oh okay yeah it's just weird
so they have multiple uh headquarters it
seems I mean this is
the this is a Hollywood building yeah it
looks like a damn USSR like public
housing like Jesus Christ it looks so
bad craziest color for a
[Music]
GI
supposed to open it hit the button if
you hit the button you did I I I it lit
I can't click
it everything else doesn't open on
screen with the dresses on that's that's
not fair because I click other and
it doesn't open it's only this
Postmates link that opens on screen
every time and I don't know why clicking
the
mouse you know what I'm saying and
Papa's in the house thank
you so we uh we we buttoned out uh AB
you should I guess go ahead from the
beginning of your drone story oh I was
just saying yeah I'm not saying that
they had anything to do with it but it
was suspicious I was trying to fly my
drone over the teddy fresh popup which
was next to a Scientology Center and my
drone completely crashed and it's never
done this before where usually if I lose
service it will come back to where
initially took off but this time just
went black and crashed was you think
they have some kind of technology that
interferes with the Drone it was
interesting I've never seen it I've
crashed my drone many times but the
screen has never gone compl and it has a
safety protocol where it goes back to
where it took off but this time it just
completely crashed and did you find the
Drone I did yeah okay destroyed oh it
was ruined yeah you know I think that's
pretty safe bet they would totally do
that maybe I don't know it was weird I'm
glad it didn't hit
anyone um I'll take the it Italian
chopped
salad thank
you with peace and love of course those
Italians I love the
Italians thank
you with no
tomatoes I don't like tomatoes and salad
I decided recently it it makes
everything
soggy it's like especially when you get
it delivered you got you can't include
Tomatoes stop with the tomatoes you're
killing soy salads are better than non
soggy salad personally yeah I have to
shake my salad for like a long time in
order for me to enjoy it wow yeah did
you just say what you wanted I couldn't
hear you I'll write it
thanks thank
you soggy salad does anyone else feel
that way
I somewhat agree really yeah I'm so
sensitive to the texture if it's soggy
at all I can't eat it the leaves need to
be like broken up a bit I feel like
sometimes it's too tough and the more
you like massage it or whatever you like
them all wet and gooey yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh man that's and I like all the
flavors to blend I don't want to have
like eight different flavors happening I
want it to be married all different
flavors I wish I enjoyed old salad cuz
for me if I I I just I can't eat it I'm
like super sensitive well if the lettuce
is wilted I'm I'm pretty out on that but
sounds like Olivia loves that you like
wilted lettuce I wouldn't say no to it
oh Jesus Christ if it's brown I won't
that's dead and it won't tastes good but
if it's like nice and soft beautiful for
me yeah I'm sensitive with fruit if it's
soft I can't eat it oh well me too with
fruit oh you're you do crunchy fruit
yeah that's what I Fu with
like not quite ripe it needs to be oh
yeah that's my that's like a banana
Banana's a different story I can't hit a
soft banana
so when it starts going brown then it's
going to be too soft for
me so but you know some people say
that's when it's when it's brown when it
starts going
brown some people do say that anyway gu
says
let's take a look at this guy who's
harassing these Scientologist very
interesting it's
it's it's super interesting because you
realize like these people act all scary
and tough and they harassing everyone
but they're not doing to this
dude and he is out there with
them watch
this streets La all the seor weirdos
look at these weird people you guys are
a Cult Don't Look Away you guys are in
such a cult where's Danny M at this
morning huh
huh you guys signed up that is so creepy
how they're
all they're walking in the middle of
damn street too what's that about for
with your billion year contract they
walking around billion year contract
what type of dumb is that do you
ever look at elron HUB see how they
cross the street just to go around me
wow look at you I need to get out of the
screen he probably feels powerful I mean
this man just made like a 100 people
walk around him I feel so
powerful
bus look at him tell me this is an ult
how's where's Danny Mar and where's
Shelly has anyone seen Shell Shell is of
course the the leaders David mavenge he
has his wife has just never been seen
from in like a decade and nobody talks
about her yeah we don't talk about her
it's really creepy really creepy uh last
publicly in 2007 bro what the okay
so it's
been it's been 16 years doing my math
right uh yeah yeah yeah what year is it
and and like nobody says anything about
it and the the leader is for sure like a
total psychopath that that's not even
even debated I don't think and I I
believe there was an LAPD investigation
and like they're like oh yeah we we saw
her she's fine they probably scared the
out of them dude Scientology
singlehandedly
um like got Church's tax exemption there
was this huge court case where they were
trying to charge uh Scientology
taxes and the case was dropped because
the prosecutor dropped it because they
were harassing him they were suing him
personally they sued him personally like
a hundred times for dumb frivolous
they were harassing him ruining his life
to the point where he was just like I I
withdraw ain't worth
it so as an organization fair enough
that's hustle culture right there they
hustle yeah that's the rise and grind
mindset where's AB is here or Olivia
okay yeah you can fact check me on that
because I'm I know the details are
really bad but s don't feel bad for
these people cuz Scientology as an
organization
is pretty dark pretty dark that being
said I think these people are story that
just it it has its own Wikipedia page
Tech status of Scientology in the United
States it's so up it's a long
tale apparently dude so up can I
uh re plug another podcast that does a
really in-depth uh
analysis of David miscavage yeah last
last podcast on the left did a really
great job of um multipart series of
giving his history and how he rose to
prominence in the oh interesting so
highly recommend that he's crazy right
oh he's a nut
yeah I was uh grabbing a fruit roll up
did you ask me to fact check something
we were just talking about the
Scientology tax stuff I think we kind of
oh yeah kind of whatever or I don't know
if you can pull something out of there
that's it's a 37-year dispute so there
it seems like there's a lot of
interesting things in there about how
they were harassing the
prosecutor but um these people are
obviously victims that being
said I have no problem with someone
being like hey snap out of it to them
even though it's not going to work not a
single person mind your business mind
your business one of their tactics is
just intimidation and life ruining
people who they consider detractors
that's ex-members that's people like
this guy here and he's like declaring
war on them so they bring out these
these people like that guy you just saw
who
specialize
in harassing them they'll follow you
they'll follow you in your car to your
home they'll put their car outside their
home they'll be photographing your home
just to make you uncomfortable filming
you everywhere you go they put a whole
ass team on you and I guarantee this
guy's being harassed to we should
contact him I got to know you looking to
get
harassed problem scient and where's
Shell at where's Shelly where was that
where's Shelly at what was that where's
Shell how did
I I don't know what you're talking about
look how crazy he gets look at the cror
weirdos look at the side get out of my
way don't don't you get my face don't
you get my face you touch me I have a
right to defend myself and I sure as
will look at all the
SE this guy all
right he out crazi him like that's
what's Wild the guy just turned around
and
started you know cuz usually there's
Clips you'll see even in the airport
people they'll follow you into the
airport three of them get in your face
and film you and call you like the worst
names don't touch me again don't touch
me again don't touch me again why are
you going to face my I'm
push
me let's look inside here don't touch me
again that's another time I told you
don't touch me let's look inside of here
you got to do that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I want to see it shut your
mouth I want to see it I really so hold
on I am so interested in his story about
why he cares so much and about if he's
being harassed a lot this guy's super
interesting though there's a whole bunch
here let's see another one making some
Scientologist recruiter scatter on
Hollywood Boulevard let's see streets La
want again is the
user oh they got all the cultist out
here look at all the cultist they got
the black one they got the black CS look
at
him look at him look at this guy check
out his coret it's tight as as
usual n don't do it hold hold as
usual hold the phone you cannot be
making wear that
that's awesome come be a uh
what the is this
outfit good question H standard fit on
the vest hold the phone man you cannot
put him out there like that you're not
going to get anyone to come inside when
dress like a damn bell
boy it's a good job being a bell boy
just
out don't do it no
no they must have a really hard time
recruiting new people these days no
don't do it it's cold there's so how
tight that is that's like a lay it you
might as well tattoo that on you man
come on
now did you ever think 15 years ago
you'd be out here doing this did you
ever think
that come on and they always got their
shoes are always too big every last
month of them their shoes are always way
too
big oh yeah another thing this is one of
the services that Scientology they have
like a whole building a whole program
that dedicated to coddling and enticing
celebrities because they know that all
these celebrities that join Scientology
is a massive influence on people coming
and joining the the church and so women
who accused Danny Masterson of awarding
them says Scientology helped silence
them while they were in the church and
that of course is corroborated we know
that that this happens in the church
that you know John Travolta Cruz those
guys are all part of this celebrity
enclave and I guarantee those
got some dark
skeletons that's how they lock him in
there but they also protect them and
they make them feel like Gods you see
how they treat Tom Cruz they hold on
hold on hold on I I think there's some
hold on Tom Cruz deserves to be treated
that well is the thing it's not a great
example pull up Tom Cruz at David
maven's birthday party yeah his buddy
best friends yeah yeah they're best
friends yeah
right yeah I mean he's Ethan Hunt I mean
he just likes to come he just likes him
because he's taller than him one guy
who's taller than
him there's a clip of Tom uh at his
birthday party wow he is little how tall
is David 5'2 whoa 52 he's a little man
52 with a little attitude 52 with a big
religious
organization
[Music]
wow FL rounds so can you reach out
Olivia or yeah let's find out are you
willing to get your family harassed for
the next 10 years
by listen I'm not is it worth it I don't
think they consider me a threat I'm not
out there harassing them if you platform
this guy and start talking about them a
lot they'll they'll come harass you also
Alexa Nicholas I don't know why You'
think that they wouldn't I've talked
about scientology a lot on this
show yeah have we really though the
documentary came out we were covering it
extensively yeah I mean it's different
to start platform be good content um
Alexa Alexa Nicholas the person we
interviewed when um the Jonah Hill stuff
was coming out she's been pioneering a
lot of um protests of Scientology right
now hold on what does she have to do
with the Jonah Hill we interviewed she
came out and said that
um I don't remember if she was on Zoe
101 yeah yeah she was on zoe1 she was at
a party when she was 16 didn't we talk
to her yeah she's a scient ex
Scientologist no no no no she's
protesting Scientology right now like
she's involved in that dude I got to say
Tom Cruz is cool as hell yeah
that's what I'm saying he deserves to be
treated that well is that Miss scavage
on the right yeah yeah yeah okay I'm I'm
rethinking Scientology
Zach's thinking of stopping by you like
that blue got I mean if I could hang out
with Tom Cruz I mean that'd be
Wicked see if you can get the celebrity
clout access this clip I just sent is
maybe the one yeah I think so I think so
this cuz this one's pretty wild I have a
time stamp to the the climax of the
video here this is like
cartoonishly look at this here I'll
St from the beginning it's only a minute
long yeah yeah I mean if you're to
answer your question seriously I really
doubt that they would bother me but if
they do then they're just another
in my life trying to bother me you're
going to take them down I mean I hate
when
people try to with you to make you
stop talking about them historically
that never worked I frankly if we didn't
live in Los Angeles I wouldn't be as
worried about it but it seems like it
wouldn't be a big hassle for them to
come harass what are they going to do
I'm literally at home or in the office
both you just said they'll follow you
home take pictures of your car weird
gated they can't get inside they might
message you on Instagram and tell you to
govern yourself
accordingly
true yeah I mean lots of people talk
about scientology it's true but I I just
specifically platforming the guy that
the that audit guy just because they he
seems to be in their crosshairs you know
what I mean I support what he does man
sure I mean I haven't seen a lot all of
it but from what I can see yeah seems
like a he's on a righteous uh a
righteous adventure and I do wonder if
it's affected if someone he loves is in
there or if he's an ex-member or
something it seems personal right yeah
it seems personal it does yeah anyway
here's
Tommy these are the times now people
okay these are the times over siiz
ass award karate medal yeah were you
there what did you
do I think you know that I am there for
you and I do care so very very very
much so what do you say when you to
clean this place up
huh they they think that
they're resolving all conflict and
issues on
Earth uh which is
interesting I don't see a lot of
empirical evidence to support that
because we're counting on you
okay all right d or
[Applause]
H what the
the other thing is
um they are so wealthy as an
organization it will make you puke their
real estate holdings that is completely
untaxed is like in the well in the
billions oh this wasn't what I wanted
but whatever you get the idea they're
besties what's the value of the real
estate holdings AB I'm seeing 1.75
billion that's nuts and about
1.5 uh yeah is in real estate yeah I
hear they just buy real estate because I
guess as a religious organization it's
not taxed at all even though as I
understand a lot of it is just
empty just to hold you know just to hold
their money hold assets yeah good
can I point out Tom his mouth once I
noticed this I've never looked at him
the same my aunt pointed out to me she's
a dentist but he has a tooth in the
middle of his mouth it's dead center
yeah he's yeah I've noticed it's just
it's a little off center it's the only
imperfection about him frankly yeah he's
got one front tooth beautiful hazel eyes
oh yeah wow bro that guy looks
fantastic for his age he does like he
looks so good man he he does he is and
he's doing his own stunts I mean it
makes you think like hm Scientology like
you see that you see what I'm saying you
see the new Top Gun wait hold on hold on
hold on he's 61 that's not super old I
thought he was older it's old for what
he does we just went and saw the new
Mission Impossible CLE months ago 40 you
think he looks the same age as
me he does not look 60 years old does
not look 60 years old I'm just saying
you see the new Top Gun that movie he's
awesome dude hold on hold on this man is
that skin is way too smooth something's
going on here he's got good work he goes
to a good guy yeah he knows a good guy
for sure it's all the DI and man
you know let's see mhm he look he he
looks phenomenal wow he's a stud man he
got to do something that tooth is kind
of stands out a lot also it seems to be
a a false tooth so it's like way bigger
than the other teeth I think it's just a
gum thing isn't
it um it could be a gum thing it could
be just a receding gum Chad's saying
it's his nose that his nose is leaning
one way so it gives an illusion that
it's not I don't think so cuz you you
line it up with the center of the
lip true right yeah yeah you're right
but I I kind of just see that too it
makes him relatable it's like that's why
he's so good cuz you know Hollywood star
he's handsome but like but like in a in
a datable way Tom's got the tooth he's
got the tooth guys he did something to
his teeth he's approachable but somehow
they didn't they couldn't get the center
it all centered up wait what's going on
in that left picture that's original
teeth when he was young really yeah I
think he's I think so yeah that's like
Outsiders not like a a meme or something
no I think that's real I think he fixed
it that could just be Dentures I think
hold the phone Zach this guy looks the
same age as me you're you're not 40
though well I'm two years off it I I'm
just saying for 61 years old he he does
not look his age I agree I just saying
this is not a a pass you or anything
like that well I'm taking it as
one well you know let's go fly some
uh f18s bro yeah he looks
phenomenal here you could see his age a
little bit here right there's a couple
pictures in the Discord that really
shows his age
or makes him a bit all right let's look
at his old ass look at this old
idiot
yeah yeah he looks like a human being
you can see his pores and at least
yeah somebody in the chat said sucks at
acting in all
caps out dude get out hold on this one
is moving the needle for me that's nor
McDonald I
know that is nor McDonald bro
who that is actually Tom Cruz that's
nuts fascinating he's I've never seen
this side of him yeah know
neither damn I mean he looks real happy
uh so I'm happy for
him that being
said just never seen that side of him
that is not the same
person hold on this
dude okay whatever I'm over it I'm out
I'm
out
um oh God what is this was a recent one
right yeah so there's something
happening here he needs another Emer
something happening get AED he may he
may you
know picked up some he may have uh been
picking up some steam a little bit
towards in the Aging department but but
that's okay I will say so I mean I've
seen all of the Mission Impossible
movies and actually Ian maybe you can
chime in on this because I with the new
one coming out I convinced Ian that he
should check out the series and you you
just watch all of them right look at
here though this is a beautiful man I I
feel like that last this last mission
impossible movie is the first one where
I was
like starting to seem kind of old just
just a just a little bit but not 61 no
definitely not but it was like
remarkable in all the previous ones it
was like this guy is still in his 20s
Ian and I have a oh you saw you it was
like Indiana Jones remember when they
brought him back right and he was old as
yeah Ian and I have a Tom Cruz chat
so like he's been like catching on Tom
Cruz movies and like we've been
discussing it so like he just watched um
f the fast Eddy movie uh color money and
uh what was the one you watched the
other night Last Samurai Last Samurai oh
that movie I like that movie we were
just talking about it it's a good flick
I mean I was just young you know when
you're younger you just appreciate
things differently but when it came out
I loved it how old was I when
that came out when that come out uh 2003
I was yeah I was like 14 or so so you're
probably 16 teenager December 1st 2003
it's 14 it doesn't have it has 66% on
Rotten Tomatoes 7.8 on IMDb really it's
rated that poorly yeah people didn't
like it and there was also lots of like
cultural
uh cultural uh appropriation or whatever
accusations I'll never forget Paul
Mooney said how are they're going to
make the Last Samurai with a white guy
he's like I'm about to make a movie
called The Last black guy on Earth with
starring Tom Hanks Tom Hanks yeah that's
funny but 0 ' 80s Cruise movies I mean
like you ever see cocktail cocktail
that's a great movie Man
someone's got Discord yeah sorry I had a
tab open just closed it uh that being
said I I loved it I thought it was
awesome anyway let's get back to
this do it C you don't want to do it
nope no look all three of them nope got
them nope nope nope and no absolutely
not oh she's going for a walk this guy's
Brave to go out there by himself on this
stuff though man you need help out I'll
help you get
out that's the location that I would
pass
by no oh you almost Prime real estate
right where the tourists are no sea sea
no no
no that's my boy streets la
I do want to point
out that Tom was not The Last Samurai in
the movie The Last
Samurai he wasn't stick no cuz did he
died at then or did he live spoiler he
lives but the other his homie died his
homie died the dad who or the brother
Wabi or whatever he's The Last Samurai
he wanted to his sister the movie
is really about him it's just told
through the right it's definitely that
guy's that character's story why first
of all love the character mhm however it
is about Tom Cruz it's told through his
eyes but the the the plot is about Tom
Cruz character the story is about his
homie look how is is he like a weeb or
something he's kind of like a weeb yeah
actually look how white he go white
looks in the DVD
cover why yeah I mean the obious L
they're going to Market it with Tom Cruz
bro but look at that hair dude
look at that
is that why you're saying that I
don't think it's real oh no but I mean I
mean he's still stunning yeah he's
studly bro it might be
real
um yeah so Tom Cruz was trying to
this dude's sister so he had to become
real tight homies with them hi sisters
and he did seal the deal if you guys are
wondering of course he
right he was trying to his sister
right pretty sure about
that what's your argument that was the
whole point right that was the story he
was like I got to do this Samurai gag no
that wasn't his sister get him oh it was
it they were related were they I don't
think so what's your argument I think it
was he she was the wife of the guy that
Tom Cruz
killed but also related but was also
related I don't know it's been like 15
20 years since I've seen the movie so
it's a little hazy I'll admit do you
think he could actually become like a
bomb swordsman in like a few years you
know what I mean well he was already a
uh Warrior if you recall yeah but
Samurai is just a whole he he was using
weapons and maybe it's like a
skar right yeah I mean yeah but he is
Tom Cruz though so and Tom Cruz walking
around with a kimono and a samurai
sword some people are say saying you
just Shawn The Last Samurai
listen that
listen that movie at a certain point
there's no such thing as a
spoiler am I right it's yeah it's 20
years 20 years it's 20 years it's is
that a fair is that a fair threshold
that after 20 years 20 just like all
bets are off with spoilers I think five
years yeah five five I think five is
maybe too soon 10 10 years
10 years what's a movie that came out 10
years ago I'll tell you Twilight would
have been 2013 yeah Twilight I guess oh
yeah that was so long 2013 movies let's
see what the big movies 2013 was like
it's less than 10 years if that's the
case grown-ups
2o Grownups
2 what the that was a good one was 2013
just a terrible year for movies what the
is this now you see me I remember
that
one wait now you see me was that the one
with Le the magician movie oh Jesse
Eisenberg right you're thinking of a
Catch Me If You Can when did that come
out
2003 so dude what a terrible year for
movies holy that was 20 years ago
okay catch me if you again what the
yeah I love that movie dude wait
wait wait 20 years ago that's up
bro
oh like I have I was like fully a
human being watching it with my family
in theer enjoying that one brother the
only decent movie I see is World War Z
from 2013 the highest ranking movies are
The Hunger Games Catching Fire awesome
okay so I guess that one has a lot of
fans Iron Man 3 which I think I think is
dog from what I remember real bad
from what I'm hearing I feel that it
it's a case by case basis yeah I guess
so 20 years though come on is that the
one with Mickey Ro no that's no that's
the second one one booted all right
let's go back to our boy streets La back
to the streets walk down there I mean
don't do Scientology cult to nothing me
no don't do it dude they're really
making them dress in that to
cult that's the craziest uniform ever
thought that I I know when you were
younger there you were never would have
thought that you'd be out here pedaling
a cult don't you think it would be way
more compelling if they were just
wearing like Street clothing and looked
like
normal or just like clean yeah I don't
know who this is targeted towards that
like it's not fancy it looks cheap and
weird they look like they're they want
to valy your car that's it yeah at at
their headquarters in La they're all
dressed like that and you know when I'm
walking down the street all the eyes are
on me cuz I do not fit in hold on they
wearing all dressed yes they all are
dressed like that yeah the vest shoes
who made dude we need a new Scientology
fashion person quick
maybe like a cute little skirt they can
do a lot better yeah tight ass por set
it's a sect it's a c
Scientology it's a Scientology it's a
cult you don't want to do it no no don't
don't mess with him look at how tight
that is he got his cor set he was like
I'm going to be a he's like I'm going to
be a star I'm going to move to LA and 15
years later he's out here he's trying so
hard to act like he's not there but he
is there and he knows he's
there
oh man that little vest is too much for
me his tight ass coret pedling this cold
now it's a cult no they're not doing
very
good it's not not very good at
all Angel they're not doing very good
tonight you're not doing well tonight
angel you're not doing well and you got
the nappy hair girl I wish they just
talk to him you guys aren't doing so
well tonight but the scientologists are
not allowed to talk to you I'm
undefeated out here tonight no it's a
cult it's a Scientology yeah that's
right no good that's right
Scientology no was like 6 nothing me 6
nothing me it's a
Scientology I do wonder if he's out
there all
night pretty dedicated
yeah uh here he is oh wow they're
threatening a family sounds pretty in
bad oh this is the same guy I love this
guy this was the guy who was harassing
him in the first
one check it out look at him down get
out of my face talk to me man talk to me
I I'm not talking to you don't is it a
different guy I don't give a about
a guy oh man they look the same you
touched me I'm going to tell you right
now look at them look at I know karate
look at
them look at them they take the bus well
he he told you to go that way you got to
go that
way this guy's filming me like I don't
like like nobody's ever seen me
documenting your
harassment documenting my harassment I'm
documenting you guys you
harass need to get out why are you in my
face why are you so interesting I find
it like Irresistible Great I'm going
find out your name in my face how many
more years left on your on your billion
year contract how many more years left
on your billion year contract huh tell
me more a billion years huh tell me more
so what's up with
Zeno dropped an atomic bomb on a on a on
a volcano and killed a billion people
that make any sense to you Zeno the Zeno
come on let me read you OTA I want to
see if you start on fire it says if I
said no I'm reading OTA don't you walk
away from dude he's better than they are
they can't compete how crazy is the
crazy they can't reading this you I need
I've never seen someone how crazy oh
he's going to S on fire it says if you
learn something you're not supposed to
know you're going to S on fire so I'm no
don't I got to read ot to you let me
read this to you no no I'm reading ot to
you I want to see if you start on fire
Fu you don't care yes you do yes you do
you're scared of me you're scared of me
what about your family you're scared of
me what about my family yeah what about
my family do they know what you doing
what oh they threatened his family wait
what happened okay I got to go back I
miss said what about your family oh
that's up but they have no
boundary if I say no I'm reading don't
you walk away from me I'm reading this
to you I need to see if you start on
fire he's going to start on fire it says
if you learn something you're not
supposed to know you're going to start
on fire so I'm no don't I got to read
ot8 to you let me read this to you no no
I'm reading ot8 to you I want to see if
you start on fire care about oh you I
don't care yes you do yes you you're
scared of me you're scared of me what
about your family you're scared of
me says you're scared of me oh yeah what
about your family yeah what about
it that's what do they even mean he's
certainly trying to say something trying
to Spook him even putting it into the
equation is kind yeah yeah yeah what
about my family yeah what about my
family do they know what you are doing
what coming after her Scientologist do
your family know what you're doing does
your family know question his family
probably hasn't talked to him in
probably not allowed to yeah so what is
this billion year contract oh so um when
you join Scientology you you you sign a
billion year contract that's when you
join the C org oh that's the C org
that's the the uh Elite members you
pledge your uh your falty for a billion
years and in case uh you think that
that's just a rumor or not true or
something here is uh on scientology.org
on their website the first C
organization members can you zoom in a
bit form first C uh or members
formulated a 1 billion year plan pledge
to symbolize their Eternal commitment to
the religion and is still signed by all
members today well it's not Eternal
they're saying it's symbolic though I'm
just saying no they believe the soul
goes on after life you're not allowed to
talk about that yet but after a billy
we're done you haven't been CLE that's
what I'm saying it's not Eternal I mean
the universe like 13 billion I mean
there'll be a time that billion expires
that is a finite contract you're right
uh and then
what you're I'm going to expect laid off
bonus for the
next try something else that you're free
agent
exactly just saying it's kind of
generous that they only do a billion
right could be
worse Scientology glaze handshaking
Mormon glaze true scientologists I'll
say as much as I say about the Mormons
scientologists are by far crazier than
than Mormons are yeah uh in
general although h
H that's
crazy uh confronting a cult that
harasses their ex-members
this is streets La that's the weirdo
mobile that's what they this why they
pack up all of elron
hubbert's
cultists they pack them on to the weirdo
bus there goes another one there goes
another one these are the guys who
harass their anybody who tries
to leave Scientology gets harassed by
these especially by security
ass like this and this guy getting
on here and all these people you harass
all your
victims right the little cultists you
guys like harassing victims and where's
Shell at have any of you seen shell
where's Shell
at and why is the Church of Scientology
giving Danny Masterson's victims info
out to harass them this gu on his
walkie-talkie like that means a
thing what do your family think about
you there they go back it up dude he
back up the weiro turn off the
light pack it up he really is bringing
it back to them like this is how they
treat everybody that they don't likeing
traffic you're illegally parked I need
you to move your truck your bus you're
illegally parked come on now you're
breaking the law you guys kiss
the ass of the LAPD LAPD need needs to
come here and ticket your
asses look at them pack it up these
people slaved all day for like 12 hours
for elron hub's cult so they're all get
on a bus at the end of the day and then
they they all live together somewhere
that's
creepy what do they do all
day like they're there all day every day
they've got a
backpack they're in their uniform what
did they do all day got to
know they play Chinese
checkers
Bingo organ
Trail they
read and made like 30
bucks cuz that's what they do it's big
pimping it's slavery slavery El don't
don't turn your head what you embarrass
you don't your family knowing where you
guys are at don't let your family
knowing what you guys are doing yeah so
there he is he's the guy we love streets
La I'd love to connect with
him um oh he's got a YouTube channel I
want I really want to know what he looks
like yeah I don't find anything on him
maybe that's on purpose s Scientology
guard hums and
[Music]
copes this is people they're not paid
for the record or they're paid like
basically nothing very very close to
nothing so they're dependent on the
church for
everything this is what happens Church
you go through no it's it's a cult this
is Scientology man dude they must
hate him he's out there every
damn day oh
damn Joker church I I wonder if he got
out of it if he if he broke through to
anyone that's the big
mystery it's over for tonight pack it up
there will not be any more recruiting
all your AC all your actions are being
recorded your actions are being recorded
then call the cops that's the property
watch this ready watch this ready watch
this dude he is a Menace shut
your mouth make the laog in all of them
are going to be documented looking to
your left to your right going to you're
going to keep breaking the law that's
what you do nobody broke the
law that's it's being documented being
do in a sense I feel bad for them in the
sense that they're cult members and
victims
but I also do uh I don't want to say
endorse endorse endorse this Behavior
but I won't say I don't
either do you know what I
mean report F
report the Scientologist are done for
tonight it's going to end up Happ what
you're going to end up happening is you
have no idea you're not a cop you're a
security guard you know what I do I post
online you know what people they laugh
at you the whole world laughs at you the
whole world laughs this guy has the
worst job in Scientology though I will
say that of all the posts you
got all the people in their cute vest
playing Go Fish
inside this dude's out there taking the
brunt of
it don't break the law break the break
the law you're going break the law
you're going to end up getting arrested
that's what's going to happen you're
going to get arrested don't break the
law you hear me don't break the law dude
they need to hire him this guy a pro up
yeah you little run it's over for
tonight God he really is
good um Cella Dragon says I was once in
I was going through the ranks and got
got out just in time I still get mail
from them I've moved four times I've
changed my name and they still found me
this is real I promise I mean I I have
no trouble believing that I am curious
how do you get out though if you're in
and you're in and then you're in and
you're so close uh I'd love to know what
it is that get out my family actually
had a family friend that back in the 70s
um went to a couple Scientology meetings
um cuz that was when they were kind of
at their Peak and it was before it was
widely known how freakish they were um
so especially in La it was pretty
popular and he kind of went and checked
it out and from the way he explains it
went to like a couple of their meetings
and then got weirded out by them and
stopped going and I remember he told me
about this about 10 years ago but I'm
sure it's still True to this day he had
a similar experience he still would get
letters sent to him all the time from
them trying to get him to come back and
like 30 40 years later moved multiple
times they will always find you and they
will always that is wild here's the
thing in the 70s and in the in the 2010s
or still yeah here's the thing I think
with all the recent really bad press
they're getting and I don't think
they're recruiting a lot of people I
think they have are having a problem
where they're not recruiting enough
people I can't imagine they're getting
too many new people and so in this day
and age how much info there is about him
they're probably trying to retain as
many people as they can but it's tough
out there to be a Scientologist these
days I mean here's here this is the
early days of Danny and Tom Cruz here's
how you sign them up put these guys on
the
street I just toss him the keys let's
just keep him in jail Tom you can do it
yeah you stay in jail right we don't
like you you're bad
yeah a lot of people say that John trola
is
gay and he's closeted
and and they hold that over him as a
thing heard that
conjecture oh look what just showed
up the so what' you get me
Dan I just got you a tie IED tea with
Boba with minimal sugar and how many
calories are we simple as it gets uh I
the the full sugar one is was 300
calories without the sugar it's probably
100 or something it's not going to be
anything most hold on hold on let's see
let me see how sweet it is thank you Sam
we'll see if they if they listened
actually do we know for cuz wait a
minute do we know which one is which cuz
mine's the same thing but with
sugar well that's another thing they
don't listen they're like no sugar
they're like sure did you say no sugar
or
less let's
see this is insanely
sweet I guess let me try this
[Music]
one this one tastes pretty sweet too I
don't know might it up this is
really
sweet well there you go another bulb of
failure for Ethan I don't know what to
tell you I tried listen is it good
yes that's not what my complaint my
thing was I wasn't sure if you would
ever had this is like the most basic
thing like the taies tea with Boba it's
not like the brown sugar blah blah blah
like a million different things this is
like as basic as it gets and I figured I
know you don't like it sweet so I said
less sugar that seems like a good order
for you but they didn't it sounds like
they didn't listen so I think the
problem is with the Tai is that the
condensed milk they use is the
sweetening factor of that is probably
add
sugar okay
oh yeah people in chat said the
condensed milk has sugar well there you
go what can you do what can you do you
can't do anything you can't do anything
I'm never going to like Boba cheers my
dude also I got to say about these
tapioca balls these are pretty calorie
dense and they're just not that good
like they're fun to chew on and all that
but it's just not that good I think
they're pretty
tasty that's all I'm saying
fine
um yeah I love him he's my
fave you don't want to do anything a
Scientologist it's a cult don't do it
right right another one it's another
one don't do it cult it's a cult
remember it's a cult cult it's a cult
it's a
cult no it's a called it's a call there
it is so we love him and there it is MHM
streets
La shout up we love them folks we really
do shout
out um next we've got we could do weird
Barber eel pit we also have the Japan
story oh yeah we should do that yeah we
definitely need to do that one that's
the one I'm excited for how how much
longer we got on the dishwasher well um
I think probably about another hour uh
the the little um clock on it I figured
would be counting down but it seems to
just be staying at the same time oh it
doesn't it still says 2 hours 40 minutes
yeah so I'm not is it on did we break it
it's on okay yeah no I hear it going
it's doing its thing uh I hope that
that's not a sign of things to come let
me go check again I checked a few
minutes ago and
it oh it's says 227 now oh it did go
down not but not enough it's already
been running for a long time it sounds
like it's hurting it might be struggling
it might be struggling does how does it
know if the dishes are clean or not
though I think it can detect uh how
dirty the water is and huh really yeah
yeah no way they don't got dirt
sensors in that maybe I think I
think that's how it can tell it's like I
still detect Gorilla Glue for some
reason yeah all right well we'll just
we're going to have to call day if it if
it breaks the dishwasher that is a funny
outcome so I think technically that
would be a fail that would be a fail
test I suppose well we got to call it
then at like 4 we just got to end it I
agree I agree we and we'll just see how
how we did listen to this if you're
dishes are especially dirty the dis
dishwasher sensor will default to a
longer wash cycle to ensure their clean
properly what is going I did not know
these dishwashers are comp it is
Advanced Tech we are living in the
future dude 2023 I don't even think
dishwashers are that expensive they're
not dishwasher price for a new
one like how do
it let's go to Home
Depot let's see let's just go down there
right now just like a normal ass one you
know what I mean let's yep yep three3
$400 I'm
seeing that is very sheap for I think
feel like a massive Appliance absolutely
it is this is These are nice ones too I
think the depot they do it
good but yeah I've always been surprised
by how affordable dishwashers can be
yeah those one for 350 bucks up I mean
these ones are expensive though these
are these are all stainless steel though
you go for like a black or white one
that's that's what yes see I don't need
the fancy let's display by price
right there I see black yeah pick one of
those hold on let's just do it by price
on the right side s by sort by there you
go lowest price low to high all right
300 bucks four stars people like it it's
a small one here's one
350 wow people don't like it it's
unbelievable this one's 370 here this
one looks this one looks legit
400 bar I what is
this it's a combination microwave
dishwasher genuinely what it's probably
counter to yeah oh it's like a little oh
for three compact for three dishes I
should get one of those let me watch
this video oh my God it has like a
window you're off you can watch it
happen you plug it to the sink I
think that's a decent size
W nice yes and you get to see it you get
a show which is a huge benefit you know
what is really nice about this is that
some houses are not wired check that out
to have dishwashers sure right and this
is a really easy way to remedy that mine
isn't wow it's only your solution it's
only like 15 easy steps to set up wait
she's going to wash she's going to
combination wait she's cooking aook food
in
there yeah it's clean yeah I can run
water it can run water over your okay
your
produce oh now I'm concerned because
it's same we need two hours
still like I wanted to do all the
steps I guess we could see where it's at
at
4 that being
said uh we have a really fun EP uh video
to watch with you guys we've actually
talked about this dude before he's a
prankster social experimentor I don't
know how to say it he's like a Mr Beast
type Creator but
like he's like Mr Beast if he didn't
have money and just harass people
yeah um this is the guy we watched this
together homeless and the most dangerous
place in America this guy went LARPing
at skid row that is awesome and he did
like uh I guess poor people
tourism homeless
tourism I don't believe he donated or
helped to improve anyone's conditions uh
1,00% just the most
parasitic bad bad intentioned video ever
and we watched it and it was it was
quite fun so here is fidus and now he's
actually getting into hot water for a
new video where he attempts to travel
across Japan without
pain and what you see uh in it
is him basically stealing a ton of
and not paying for public
services and Japanese people uh people
abroad everywhere see this and just
despise him and and me too the premise
of the video he's going to travel from
Nagasaki to amori without spending any
money participants begged for free rides
criticized a bus driver over a fair
dispute evaded staff and checks hit it
in a train restroom used a fake hotel
room for free buffet oh yeah they were
stealing buffet food from a
hotel what the
so here let's let's watch you
know so here oh wait it was
removed removed for Community guidelines
yes y we that just happened mhm we do
have it backed up but all of our
time stamps were off of the you I was
going to watch the whole thing anyway
it holy Japan is all about the
respect damn dude so I was looking I was
watching clips of it right before we
went live so within the last within the
last two hours this is this is a serious
operation do you guys what I'm saying we
backed it up yeah this is not going to
slow us down at the a Street podcast
hell yeah brother Dan made sure he's
like did you back it up a good no no
don't say that don't say that what I
will say is we'll put up the disclaimer
that we disavow what he's doing in the
strongest terms
possible sounds good back up back up we
packed it up that was me yesterday I
wonder what they got him for stealing
doing crime yeah probably all the crime
are you allowed to do
crime I think generally no what's really
funny about this guy too is like he's
such a piece of and Mr Beast loves
him he's been in like three of his
videos they're like he's actually been
in Beast videos where he won a car or
some
yeah wow got
removed the homeless I can't believe it
but I guess going to spend the next days
homeless in Los Angeles with the last
day being the I think YouTube was under
a lot of pressure um I was starting to
read quite a bit of people talking about
it yeah and they might have been headed
towards a suicide forest situation yeah
exactly after Logan probably want to
play it SA about that by now I mean
in a sense like what he's don't doing
is um while what Logan Paul did was
insanely callous and Psychopathic he's
he's
actually stealing and doing crime
across the whole country it's like a
crime tourism
video so it's it's arguably worse I
would say yeah cuz that this is like a
genre video of like travel video of like
going somewhere and spending as little
money as possible but you know there's
way to there's ways to do that without
ripping people
off travel cheap you know yeah of course
he took that concept with just like oh
yeah I can do this for no money just Rob
people yeah you can see you you get the
idea though just looking at his
thumbnails this morning I watched some
of that Elon mus video
that was he really unbelievably painful
cringe like top top top shelf cringe
right there it's a hard watch for very
difficult
watch he like he just harasses Elon Musk
for like a month or two until Elon like
gives in and like you can tell that they
were really not happy about it but they
had like a social media campaign
pressuring him uh leing a billion
comments like you got to hug this guy
you got to hug this guy I got to say I'm
his he gets pretty good views but I'm
happy to see he's not getting more I see
like a million per video yeah because
he's do these obscenely ridiculous kind
of thumbnails all like beasted
out and um it's not really working for
him right now three months ago I got
handcuffed to 100 strangers 500,000
views wow
Lop that's a flop right there that is a
flopo so with all that being said our
friend here who just got a strike this
is so sad can someone go follow him on
Twitter I want to see if he has any if
he's saying anything about it yeah
yes but anyway here's the backup how
exciting
um you remember Bill W's video the
history of Japan mhm yeah it's like that
right very similar concept what is that
guy up to I'm going to travel across is
he still posting I remember we had him
on like didn't he do like yeah he came
first interview was with one of his only
interviews first and only interview yeah
yeah um he's probably working on
whatever his next video is going to be
which will probably come out in five to
six years and get like 400 million views
yeah he hasn't uploaded in 10
months he has five and a half million
subs and this man is one of the most
interesting oh he was like kind of on a
roll recently Well yeah if he was doing
for a while these cute little whatever
videos oh and people were enjoying them
however I he told me at the time that he
wanted to start work on another big one
MH like the history of the entire world
dude that video was insanely good and so
viral was so
viral vas's last tweets from October
22nd he said I traveled across Malta for
free he did it again in another country
cool he did in the US too I saw that was
October 22
mhm we haven't heard from him I think he
got killed probably up
there the thing about Japan too is like
they have a very
cordial Society where people are
expected to follow like really strict uh
cultural norms and stuff and I feel that
he's taking advantage
of the Norms of their society right in a
really disgusting way anyway I'm going
to go pee and then we'll watch it I'll
be right back okay sounds
good okay I want to take this moment to
ask the audience for help on
something I am in a situation with my uh
moving that's going on me and Lena we
supposed to move into our new apartment
this weekend and uh we found out that
our new place only offers 10
MVPs uh internet speed tragic insane I
thought our old place was bad with a 100
and I didn't even ask because it's the
same building and also I didn't even
think it be worse that's crazy but yeah
so it's 10 and uh that's the only like
hardwired cable internet that I could
use so I need Alternatives because I'm
freaking out because we paid a lot of
money for this place we're already
packed up and yeah I don't know I was
considering starlink or uh like Verizon
or T-Mobile home internet but if you
guys have any suggestions send them my
way thank you God bless have you
considered um the the
telegraph the telegraph
yeah like the old art
of uh yeah where you use a little
communicator and um Morse code and you
communicate yeah it kind of sounds like
that thank you Z no I have considered
crashing in your guest room though Dan I
know you get good great internet yeah
you can stream from my place for sure
you got like a thousand or some
like that not even yeah stream is one
thing but it's like even just watching
uh Netflix and I don't even know
what I could do with 10 I can't work
from home with 10 like that's insane
dude you got to ask where you lived
before one of your neighbors run a wire
pay them like 1,000 bucks a month or
some like some so they go for okay
like 200 bucks that that was
honestly between the balconies or some
I don't know the thing was
they had a contract with AT&T and they
didn't resign and so they sort of AT&T
is trying to get the building to like
Strongarm them into resigning so all the
new people are only getting 10 and if
you have 100 it's because you were
already there so I'm 100 yep yep
well unless you can find uh somebody who
works at the internet company to bribe
that's a I think you might be in trouble
I see a lot of people suggesting the
Starling thing I mean I I don't know how
expensive or like viable it is to to do
that
but
might Ethan saying what are you
saying he's saying the dishwasher is
going through something um yeah we can
see if we can pick that up hold on let
me turn the receiver on
okay so it says 2 hours 12
minutes churning a lot of churning going
on yeah I noticed that as well I'm very
curious to
uh to see if it survives us that it
would
the fact that it's adding time I don't
know how I feel about that yeah uh for
the
experiment yeah it's on yeah that's a
good point it's just yeah sure you can
just add infinite amount of time and
it's going to clean anything yeah
exactly can you hear
it are you holding it up to the
dishwasher AB I'm right up to it all
right it's loud as oh wait here we
go oh yeah starting to hear it I turned
the gate
off that's our that's our boy at work
doing its thing 2 hours 12 minutes
baby all right thank you it's struggling
man
along hold on I've skipped the whole top
of the show where there's a whole bunch
of stuff I wanted to read you did why
did I do that
uh you were just so eager to talk about
rolling balls that you just kind
of went right into that but but we're in
the middle of talking about uh let's do
this yeah I don't want to get
sidetracked but there's a whole bunch of
good stuff still I want to talk about
all right here we
go for free against this and then and
then hold on we need the
disclaimer we need the uh we disavow
this idiot
mhm one moment
we dis out everything
said by these idiots can we say that
dumbass alert we just out everything
said by this loser that one that's the
one but it's covering it does cover you
so uh can you shrink it and just move it
to the
left that's fine I
mean top right corner it's actually
perfect cuz he did air he does arrows
pointing at them all yeah we just about
everything said by these losers doing
the pointing for us thank you
all right this seems fine good enough
yeah and the winner gets
$10,000
start don't know why all these YouTubers
always running it's more difficult to do
this as a woman good luck than while I
was running I found some people in the
bus station and they told me that the
bus worth 600 Yen I see for don't trust
this man he kills people don't trust
don't
trust they don't speak English the bus
is coming and I have no
to give me some money oh my I love you I
love you so so he's begging he's he's
already pan handling from uh the
Japanese populace it's $4 us oh that's
actually pretty pricey for a bus ride
it's all about the
respect this is our bus let's see if he
will ask me for
money okay he didn't ask for any money
and just like that I was way ahead of
every just went onay people pay when
they go out of the bus to go down so
hopefully he doesn't ask me to pay what
do you expect him to do six only this 80
no no 80 no police no no on police
station ATM I don't know what he he you
don't know he's saying ATM he's saying
go get money yeah here's the thing once
again this is really not in this culture
I feel like like this is crazy behavior
yeah like they don't this is not normal
mhm it's all about the respect I
got in trouble guys it's more than
anything about the respect couldn't
believe it he lock me in the bus so now
he's being trapped on the bus drove me
to the police station just because I was
8 in short in the police station they
started interrogating me and they took
my phone away so I couldn't film
anything already this is not dude this
man got he got arrested already like
instantly that is kind of fny that they
arrest him for four bucks because they
don't around with this crazy
behavior no no he was short 53 cents us
basically he was short 53 cents and they
arrested him that's what Japan it's all
about the respect baby go that is kind
of wild that is wild uh you got to love
Japan I find it interesting you pay when
you get off too I've never heard of that
pay when you get
off okay maybe because people don't act
like this over
right easy as I thought it was going to
be I think I'm going to have to start
asking people to borrow some money do
you understand like anything like little
dude begging for money is just so
sad pathetic cringe embarrassing
for them like Rich YouTubers begging
yeah common people for money it's crazy
W let's go we got given some change
using the same method AKA collected
money for the bus and he collected for
the train FAS loses his Challenge and he
has a lot to lose because he built up
his reputation as the best hher in the
world but his friend here is going to
show him otherwise at this point it's
been hours that the police is holding me
and everyone passed me I'm by far the
last we are traveling to foka and this
city is so beautiful byebye so thank you
they're racing to the north of Japan and
all just got on a
bus mhm awesome yeah let's see who buses
faster
man my God guys I spent the last 5 hours
with the police and after they got bored
of me for 5 hours they paid for my thing
all this story we're talking about 20
cents I'm the okay it's not really
up to you to decide how much of a stink
they make you're the one that stole that
and look how serious they are about
the police had to pay the the remaining
balanced so that he could leave fny like
jeez
man last now definitely I'm the last now
I need to keep traveling I think I need
to convince someone to purchase a ticket
for a train will you be able to purchase
me a ticket for next St yes I will oh my
God thank you so much have arriv is
actually paying for my ticket thank you
Joseph for the ticket so the police
already knows me I'm going to disguise
myself now me disguised I'm ready to
sneak in the train this is my train so
let's hope that nobody gets me and now
it's time to teach you how to get the
train for free so I'm entering the train
and I will find the toilet and go
straight to the
toilet dude this is insane
Behavior I will teach you how to ride
just got out jail you're you literally
just got out of jail we've been over
this man you were in you were detained
for 5 hours over 50
cents oh God this is pure degenerate
Behavior lock myself the whole time in
the bathroom the whole time what do
people need to go yeah oh suckers
they're knock the door bro what this
guy's insane my door he's he's just
insane he's just in the bathroom people
are pounding on the
door this is not normal behavior man oh
boy was loged the person who collected
the tickets came and open it fortunately
this guy is such a
dumbass the ticket collector is still
looking for that ticket bro he so me
pretending to use the bathroom and left
we're again so I came to my
destination now I think he's waiting for
me outside and I was right he was just
waiting to catch me so the only thing I
could do is to pretend that I'm
sick Bro this he he needs to stop I feel
this should be career ending I'm seek I
mean this is apparently got a strike so
it's one step closer to
that I'm this this is
nuts dude this is a police
officer or is that the train guy it
might just be the train he
looks yeah I don't know I don't know
I'm just gonna pretend I'm sick
[Music]
Bro I mean like the fact that they got
to deal with this from
foreigners come on you know how long it
took Japan to open up uh to the World
Trade right yeah you know you you guys
are about to make them go uh close it
off again we're closing the Silk Road or
that was China wasn't it sound like
that okay
he's running he's running from the
authorities he's trying to run from the
police cuz he when I sat down he
released me and immediately I started
running but you're filming yourself
doing
crimes police and they are searching for
me now definitely get in trouble here I
ran straight to the next train I had to
catch and I was hoping that the train
will come before the police it's so
intense for me I'm sure the others don't
have this experiences there are ticket
inspectors on this train so I'm hiding
in the toet stressful God what is
how could all these people come together
collectively and decide that this was a
good
idea holy man I'm not going to lie
it's get into my nerves L me the train
oh that's sick I've never seen their
bullet trains arriv before the police
could find me again we're going to do
the same method
[Music]
toilet it was really successful last
time he's been caught every single time
so
far let's see if he gets away with it
again three times a intensity level 100
in the challenge we need to follow all
the instructions my teacher give us or
we get disqualified hi guys I have a new
rule for you from
he just he doesn't introduce him he just
says the teacher makes the rules and
teacher yeah he calls in a few times
like Morpheus and tells him what to do
next a station you are not allowed to
use any
train good luck there's no more trains
allowed from this point on something oh
it could be I think he just told him
what to say someone in his family looks
like no more trains guys with peace and
love which is coincidentally my next do
so that must mean we're first guys so I
made it to okama station so what I'm
going to plan to do is take a bus can
you uh help me with money for the bus so
pathetic don't you have so they're all
going to give me 2,000 oh my
God it's so up bro they begging
for
money and it's probably so weird for
them to see like a foreigner coming and
begging them for money that they're
almost like just give it out of like
shock mhm 2,000 Yen he said how much is
that 2,000 yen is 13 bucks nice
H I've heard of phenoma in Japan of
forers like traveling the world and then
just begging for money to keep traveling
that's like a somewhat common thing in
Japan actually oh I have heard
about that too and it's very very
frowned upon yeah it's crazy yeah it's
crazy it's insane come to a country if
you don't have money you know what I
mean cuz there's homeless people there
who would benefit from that money
actually you know like to eat what is
the homelessness like in Japan um I'm
not sure personally but I know there is
a bit kind of
curious tense video I did in my life I
can't believe that this is real and not
the movie I made it to okama that was so
much aniy I hated that we arrived in the
okama station hopefully the ticket guy
is not waiting outside so we did it we
are at okama station and from now on we
are not allowed to use PL now the
challenge becomes more interesting oh my
god look who it is
nightscape oh my God bro I'm happy that
I see your face yeah man it's
nice to see you bro you want to go
together in Tokyo I'm down we need to
find a bus I've looked for buses and
there's no buses that go from here to
Tokyo we've got to keep mwing and
purchase a ticket and go to uh compared
to other countries the oh here I want to
read this the visibility of homelessness
in Japan might seem relatively low the
lower visibility is partly due to the
stringent public regulations and social
norms which discourages people from
sleeping in the streets however the
issue still exist people experiencing
homelessness in Japan tend to congregate
in specific areas such as Riverbanks
Park
and around train stations and urban
centers interesting it was really bad in
the 90s and they put in some uh policies
to help with that in the early 2000s
they call it the Lost decade in the
90s they're like just as long as we
can't see you then yeah it's all good
the recru are approach oh my God right
right oh oh my God oh my gosh guys
FAS and nightcap they are here oh my my
God oh my gosh this is getting real so I
just asked the bus driver he could take
me but he said that the bus is
completely full and the next bus that's
getting out of here is like till
tomorrow at 4:30 in the evening so this
guy has invited me to stay in his house
until my BS in the morning so maybe
don't don't do
that I will actually take up on his
office this guy is crazy bro I'm not
like that I cannot shout like that it's
it's mental so play the game to see who
will give us
money he lost so he is responsible to
give us money oh my God thank you thank
you okay and just like that we made
15,000 together and we splited the money
it's been great to collaborate with you
but it's time it's time to leave good
luck brother may the best man win yes so
there is no buses because it's midnight
so the only thing to do is to hit trke
probably I should go out start hit
tracking but now I'm so scared do you
know karoke karoke you want to go
karaoke so we're going to go to karaoke
and then I'm going to sleep over his
house so we made it to karaoke so I just
left the train station and I immediately
found a ride I found this girls here oh
I love Japanese people they're so cute
did you see that I think you looked away
but was not as lucky as me yeah I'll go
back made it karaoke so we're going to
go to karaoke and then I'm going to
sleep over at his house so we made it to
karaoke so I just left the train station
and I immediately found a ride I found
this girl here oh I love Japanese people
they're so cute and polite dude dude is
so patronizing isn't it I love the
Japanese they're so cute and polite
nobody knows how to handle my psychotic
freak
energy so they just do what I
say thank you thank you but AA was not
as lucky as me he taking no cars are
willing to even put their glass down and
respond it's getting harder and harder I
have received a checkpoint I'm praying
is Tokyo I'm going to play this video
now the first checkpoint is Koto exactly
you have to
be when you get to Koto and the last
person gets eliminated oh oh
it's the guy it's the dude it's the
teacher
Morpheus we got to get to Kyoto I might
be eliminated I'm far behind right now
I've been here in this train station for
about 6 hours and if I'm the last there
I'll get eliminated and here I am
playing karaoke this is good I'm getting
close to Kyoto
yes you're crazy they're crazy as well
they're
[Music]
crazy I'm still at the station all I'm
going to do now she is having a Min time
just have her like walking around at
night too trying to hitchhike it it gets
a lot worse does it wait till the end
for her specific she doesn't make it she
was killed uh she's still missing the
video is actually dedicated to her this
is for our front
Agatha rest in peace you you died doing
what you loved
right so it was a valiant death crying
on the side of the road trying to get
picked up by I pan
handling in foreign countries I was
sleeping and Nick was singing night gape
was cooking s if you go to Kyoto it will
be an adventure you'll never forget I
understand that I do understand okay
accept it okay my God you see
the size of this cucumber slice this is
kind of crazy isn't it oh it's keying
out yeah no it looks pretty small to me
there you can see the size oh wow oh wow
look at that thing oh why so big
who's you know what I mean it's too
big way too big get
real so this guy has just agreed to let
me drive his car to Kyoto I can't
believe I managed to do this I thought I
was losing I might actually have a
chance of winning this now thank you so
much bye-bye byebye they are so cool so
they dropped me to a big gas station
here so kyoda is just an hour from here
so I think I will find people that go
there I asked them and they're thinking
about it let's
see no no been getting rejection after
rejection Al it's like 4:00 a.m. in the
morning I'm tired guys as you can see
it's empty there is nobody here but all
of a sudden a stranger saw me struggling
and accepted to take me in his car to
Kyoto Oh weird weird what was that why
he have a Norwegian flag on and accept
empty there is nobody here but all of
had an stranger saw me struggling and
accepted to take me in his car to Kyoto
God so this guy thought I was having
like a schizophrenic episode was worried
about my being lost in a foreign country
actually I'm just being actually I'm
just making a YouTube video and begging
for
money nobody would see that
coming and they're saying that my
victory is confirmed because they got me
a bus going directly to Kyoto in the
morning
cannot believe this this is insane shout
out to These Guys these are my friends
for life I love them let's make our way
to Kyoto I think we might be the first
ones there now maybe FAS might be us who
knows this is the famous temple back in
the night wow this is so
beautiful so I made it and uh is that
for real she's sleeping on the
street
up doesn't she know she's supposed to go
down the riverbed the other guy the
other guy doing karaoke like partying uh
one guy got picked up by two girls he's
got a nice ride and then this poor girl
is sleeping on the
concrete she'll make it there she'll be
fine yeah this is the house I will be
staying I'm coming for you foras I think
I'm first here but all the other
competitors are very strong so we did
the same videos in United States
one we did this in UK and night we did
this in India and one by the way YouTube
um
moderators check definitely watch those
videos he just mentioned cuz those are
probably also init is just the same but
in other
countries let's get him banned for life
guys
America
England I think the same video One in
United States Nick one we did this in UK
and nightscape one and we did this in
India and ala one out of 12 people they
are there you go that's four strikes
man beautiful the best here and now
we're going to see who is the best hit
Che care in the world so the sun is
rising it's becoming day two guys I'm so
lucky to be alive just so grateful I
just love this beautiful life so I just
arriving this BS station from here I try
to get a bus to Tokyo coming station has
opened up I am waiting for my bus to go
to Kyoto I think I'm the last one
because it's obvious they all moved on
even though I tried hitchhiking nothing
work good morning I was regretting my
decision oh is this is this real why
does it have so little
views oh maybe what wa does it have a
little views I traveled across Europe
for free here he is hiding in the
suitcase comp Department with a off
police officer looking for oh maybe it's
fake I don't know this not his channel I
mean this is 1,00% real 45 views it
doesn't make any sense yeah it's like a
copy Channel well if you if you Google
that nothing happens I'm looking for the
original in the night that I didn't
decide to hit chke it's 8:00 now so I'm
here at the bus station take me directly
to Kyoto it's a fake channel oh I don't
know what that was who weird what's on
it when you click it wait what it's like
a weird copy cat Channel yeah
look why copy this dip we are now
in
the 21 subs and it's like a reupload but
it like looks exactly like his channel
hold on hold on hold
on hold on I have absolutely nothing I
have a theory he has different channels
is it translated or something oh yeah
it's to he totally removed the original
all different flavors cuz I see a bunch
of reuploads but not so was the his
original video
removed yes it seems like
[Music]
it I wonder if that just happened also
maybe is the India or us one there those
are that is the original
thumbnail I can no I have no trouble
believing that thumbnail is
real it's like every other thumbnail on
this channel
[Music]
there's some other ones oh
slick he's promoting other
videos he used the same
thumbnail for Europe sh and what
wherever this is you see the one this is
India you can see it's
uh someone was looking to beat me up
with a stick this dude in riot gear was
looking going to kill
me who's believing that
man wow this guy's a
what the look at this
thumbnail he on to the top of the train
think's yeah exactly so did you find the
Indian or American one no they're all
taken down yeah I don't see oh so they
all got got very
possibly this another well I traveled
around the earth for free is up this one
is still
this one from 7 months ago 2.7 million
views so not all of them here click
around this this is his real Channel
yeah or no I thought he had more subs
than that he only has two million this
is
it huh he sold his he got one more now
he sold his soul to this Beast format
and the man can't even get over 2.3
million dude come
on was relaxing and okay whatever let's
let's continue on the Japan one you guys
for the
best is there good stuff coming up BBE
so we finish watching it I would skip
his friends I would just there's a point
at the end where Agatha I think we
should watch but his friends Parts I
would just skip okay yeah who cares L
losers yeah don't
care this is the hotel oh this is the
hotel he's sneaking in for breakfast oh
this is good this is good and then act
like I have a credit card that's us
so now while I'm waiting the bus I will
try to get some free breakfast this is a
hotel I went up to the rooms to check
the number so I could use it as a
passcode for the bre
dude you should not be telling people
how to do
this this is crazy I'm going to go steal
a meal or get this room charged if he
gives them the room number they're going
to get charged for his meal breakfast
room 5 05 thank you and it worked I just
you just stole money from a random
guest have access to a five star
Japanese buffet and we're leaving the
without getting caught and without any
problem
he do you not realize
that it's free food dude it's not free
food it's free food that's literally put
someone else other guest name I love
that he's wearing a shirt this is Mafia
just Mafia yeah badass good thing he's
got a a discreet look no will recognize
him especially in Japan
yeah this is My BT all right shall keep
going yeah that breakfast one was nuts
this guy's just stealing
that's like the whole
video checkpoint coming up can we just
on the show can we just have like like
uh gabee or just you know not even Gabe
somebody that nobody knows just
occasionally call in and just tell you
that you've done a good job and you've
reached a new checkpoint Ethan it's kind
of like the video game like snake
or whatever yeah exactly like somebody
just calls in real quick in the corner
just like hey Ethan great job you just
hit the 2our mark keep going you're
almost through the podcast yeah it's
exciting I'll be down pre-record some
stuff with Gabe I'll see what I can do
in
Tokyo
keep going yeah U I'm going to look at
the backup myself the next good point is
they're both on a bus from Tokyo I'm I
think oh yeah the the time stamps don't
work cuz it was a race yeah can you tell
me the what time it appears yeah I'm
looking it right now it
is he stole oh yeah I remember in the
homeless one he stole a sleeping bag
from a homeless person so this is my bed
for the night I stole this from a
homeless P he literally just said that
how Shameless this man has
nothing they have nothing and you still
stole from
them that is he has nothing
now but I will put it back in the
morning need very c one person worked in
the
park dude he's such a
h you find the time stamp baby
oh man I'm trying there's so many good
moments all right um everyone me and you
oh my it will take me ages to go out of
the city
guys now we are actually figuring out
how to go from here to the next point
he's helping me to board the other car
as well he did not just drop me oh yeah
this is great she's just hitchhiking in
random cars he managed to convince a
person of the to drop me off to the next
top after that it's going to be
difficult I guess oh it's back yeah it's
back we passed
it thanks a lot YouTube you hadn't
banned this video made The Bu so would
have had time
stamps oh my
God yes hello we have nightscape in the
same bus with me
again I'm always one step behind no he
was two steps behind behind he sneak in
the bus and the bus driver noticed him
no no no no no I pay I'll give you no no
the bus is full so nightcap is not going
to make it in this bus so unfortunate
I was on the bus Tokyo and that is
the only bus to Tokyo today so now my
only option is to get a flight an old
man help get the he going to steal a
flight complain that seems hard he's
been with me for more than 30 minutes
now he's like a guardian he going around
and then asking information yeah imagine
he actually thinks you probably are are
in danger or need help like actually
yeah it's crazy that you're actually
just don't care that he's he's really
doing something going way out of his
wife for you yeah he just thinks you
actually need help but you don't at all
if you go back to
1915 here we go yeah figuring out how to
go from here to the next point he's
helping me to board the other car as
well so this guy who she randomly met
and asked for a ride took her to this
parking lot to meet up with another
person to take her wait wait wait
he like another person he knows it's it
wasn't clear but that's what it s oh
yeah that's that's they're they're going
to kidnap her next traffic I'm saying it
was like the easiest kidnapping ever oh
no thank you so much so he managed to
convince a person get the TR wait drop
me off to the next top after that it's
going to be difficult I guess but uh
yeah can you go ahead and just put this
duct tape around your an yeah and you
just hop pop in the trunk HP in the
trunk here got it all open for you very
good your cell phone please turn
yourself up I'm going to cover your
mouth in duct
tape just cuz I like to ride in silence
you
know for keep progressing like this
because compared to yday this is like a
100x progress I'm mean car h a king and
they offing me
wow oh my God so good oh my
God brought me guys to the freeway yes
byebye I love you they were going home
and they went one hour out of their way
you should feel bad that's horrible they
think you actually need help man just to
take me here they brought me to
best yeah not the not anything they can
do for
right whatever all these cars are going
to the freeway in the direction that I
want them you see when you're doing is
this should I keep watching I love this
quote right here yeah okay okay great
stuff you meet people in the best way
possible like there is no other way that
you can have these interactions if you
are not traveling for free no other way
can I come with
you what a
about that okay we we skip this
part 1840 this is the the only other one
we skipped okay let's see
1840 when something's failing you need
to Pivot so I cannot stay more time in
that gas station so I got closer to the
highway and I was lucky to find a ride
thank you I got picked up by
this what the you sick sick
dude man that little girl's body
language she's like get away away no he
goes they don't like the Flash oh my
God they don't like the Flash in their
eyes oh he's in the back with the
super bright light at night dude
what the out of parents are
these the parents probably thought he
was Ninja that's the only reason they
let him in the
car K LOVE ninj hey kids look at the
camera what's wrong let put this
Spotlight in your face I got
picked up by this beautiful they don't
like the Flash in their eyes they
probably just turn it off then
huh byee he keeps it on he keeps it
on you I was Stu in the gas St that kid
was saying leave he wasn't saying bye he
was shooting him out when I change my
behavior and I pivot to do a different
thing it worked so this is the lesson
for everyone me and you oh my will take
me ages to go out of this I hate
him he's just
so he's just so comfortable using things
cynically it's really
nasty wait wait wait what the is
this I found on crazy what is this
is this podcast highlight Channel 10
views yeah and is like the weird he just
he has a a philosophy podcast oh
interesting hold on hold on this guy's
making Tom Ward look like
PewDiePie
he has the weirdest highlights
here here let me
see send me that
channel okay 100 views here this one has
20 views from 5 days ago how is that
possible man dude you got to read some
of the titles the titles the topics you
live in a world dude the title is why
marriage can be a
problem one like what the he's talking
to a guy in his closet he is yeah he's
he's in a closet he's asking so fun
questions check this time stamp hold on
this is hard I'm taking this in
still oh how is it that he get millions
of views and then here he gets 22 views
in five
days are these up re-uploads is this
just like a like a fan clip Channel or
something I don't know the Channel's a
year old and has 8K Subs here it is it's
linked
how's the evidence Mar happy it has 440
views so not a lot huh Fest podcast here
it is it's got 18,000 a gun what are
these he's still doing it he did one
from two days ago he's
grinding let's see why is M marriage a
problem where there's only one
relationship the equivalent of marriage
or being single if you're try trying to
make that marriage work but it doesn't
work because it's not exactly the right
fit this is super
[Laughter]
interesting bro I I think whatever you
did happened to you in divorce court is
probably interesting but I have no idea
what what you're talking about that's
why a marriage doesn't work in a closet
exactly what I was thinking it's very
easy to think that there's something
wrong with you but when you're not me
remember it's not you that's wrong it's
the world that's wrong to choose from a
big menu of
relationships and you're able to
successfully find and develop a
particular style of relationship that
works for you you no longer think that
there's something wrong with you yeah
for example I just go to Thailand once a
year for sex
tourism and that's just fits right into
my
appetite what is wrong with you
right now you just realized that there
was something wrong with the
with marriage hold on hold on what the
is happening is he is this real
hold on hold on on I sent you a time
that where he actually talks hold on he
just sits there like this yeah it looks
like an image
though what the he looks baked out
of his mind
bro marriage but there was something
wrong with the I thought someone was
doing a gag look at this with marriage a
tradition at doing there's not something
with one of these other
versions yo Dan okay here's what we need
to do realiz that there was something
wrong I just need to pop him up
occasionally his live reaction to our
show oh man this is crazy dude marriage
a traditional marriage but there's not
something wrong with one of these other
versions you know this I think two Ang
Society honestly of this problem I think
this is one of the biggest problems ever
now he looks like a student in a zoom
class falling asleep and then gets
called on by the
teacher I wanted to so true that is this
with you
because I still don't know what they're
talking about if you ask
anybody they want they feel forced to
get married I was talking like a couple
of days ago with ultra Ultra successful
and that he was he's 38 years old and he
just feel he's just actively searching
for a wife that he they need to have did
you say he's 58 38 well that could Pro
probably explain his behavior a little
more KS and he feels the pressure from
his parents and all this stuff and we
have this uh this thing that uh these
expectations that when you hold on he
just said a 50 8-year-old is getting
pressure from his parents to get married
how old are his parents 100 it's
that dude in the closet what the oh
38 okay that makes more sense find that
then your life will be amazing which
always expectations is the enemy of of
any happiness in life expectations is
the enemy of Happiness ourselves
completely like this is like a game that
we cannot win if we have this
expectations and all this other stuff
but hey it it's crazy now I'm kind of
showing you how passionate about about
this topic
but oh man we do we we we have a good
podcast
here uh what else they got here this I
can't get enough of this frankly um why
you should treat relationships like a
business hold on that's interesting
that's
interesting I I love let's can I look up
the credentials on his guest let's see
oh it doesn't even say the
guest it's just a divorce I love
your that you are taking a relationship
like a business uh not not like a
business but like the methods of
improving a business and improving I
will definitely use that going forward
to treat also not
it's a bit not all the
relationships maybe becomes a bit more
crazy when you do the relationship with
your friend with ar friend with your
family with all but yeah with the more
intimate close relationships I think is
important to see what he
saying did you get that what what is he
saying well he the way he edits it is
like makes no sense he's saying this guy
said to run a relationship like a a
business and he liked what he said right
but he didn't show what he said right
just that he liked what he said oh I'm
just realizing what's going on here it's
AI
cut huh yeah I think it's an AI cutting
the and editing the
video taking wouldn't there be more
though cuz it's not like he's spamming
like Mass spamming it's like every few
days even it's not even I I know a tool
that does exactly this kind of content
he does seem like a guy who' be like AI
is the future well he's busy he's busy
uh doing a crime spree across Japan that
time to e clipse a prolific
Thief well known across the world Carmen
San Diego
I but you know I would argue you
can use these principles for any
relationship again again we don't say
what's the
principles we just say that we like them
right and this is a good highlight
so let's talk about um a relationship
with a parent for example right so
remember there are
norms associated with parent child
relationships where are you going with
this
bro I don't Zach I think um frager has
something to say about
this what's your argument see no that I
don't like that right so one Norm is you
call your father dad or father you don't
call him Phil or Joe or Pal deep right
kind of a thing why would I call my dad
Joe filler Al his name is
Gary doesn't even make sense dude here's
an example of a few names that your dad
might be
called idiot you could both agree thank
you this is the show anyway as I was
saying
um yeah dude relationships are like
businesses bro trust me you got to treat
them like oh we just got to get we only
have a few yeah
yeah I love fidas he's my favorite on it
that you're going to use first names and
you're going to call your father by his
first name for
example right you know and so you could
engage in relationship design for
example if you're feeling a lot of
pressure from your family about getting
married right and so you could say hey I
want to talk
about um so Bor how we interact around
my
lifestyle um and to say to you that um
I'm happy for you to give me your
opinion about my lifestyle but I only
want you to give it when I ask for it
that's really good advice listen Mom I
love you but please shut the up
stop and as you know uh mothers are
extremely receptive to that kind of they
love hearing that advice can you do that
for
me and so then when your parents just
out of the blue say honey you really
should get married you'll be much
happier you can say hey Mom or hey Dad
you know I just want to remind you that
I'm happy to hear your is he op is that
just static but not wait is he moving oh
there
you dude I wouldn't I I wouldn't be
surprised if he blinked and like closed
his eyes at a certain point and he
chopped it and froze it at certain point
so you don't see it no way you be much
happier that sure looked like a PNG for
a minute you can say he's moving okay
there he I just want to remind you that
I'm happy to hear you there though he
Frozen that boy does not blink no he's
moving opinion but not
unsolicited is and and you can agreee on
parents who love their kids that's the
most impressive thing he's done are
going to say okay I'll give you my
opinion but I'll I'll wait for you to
ask for it you know that yeah yeah I'll
tell you what
man my kids ain't asking for my opinion
they're getting it you can decide if you
want to take it or not mhm but I'll be
God damned if my kids are going to tell
me to shut the up right while L's
opinion I love you I hate your ideas
don't respect
you and so you could use these same
principles and you could just check in
Mom Dad how's it going you know like
they could say what you think about our
relationship as well like this is a big
philosophic again it's called why should
you treat relationships like a
business I didn't even catch that
there's literally no it's analogy in
this no question what do you think about
Rel Single Living in a closet if you
follow this advice mhm prove it like
yeah I never thought to do that with my
parents or my friends and we this is
more like the intimate partner that
you're searching this is more normal to
do this yeah and I think the stakes are
higher with those Intimate Relationships
but the principles are the same the
principles are the same you know like
for example you could you in the same
way that you set up dates right you
could have this guy's closet's pretty
sad if you analyze it like look at these
little piles
right white
underwear a divor man closet he's got a
whole set at least he's folding it could
just be like he doesn't have a lot of
clothing one crew neck this guy has like
minimalism all boring clothes he's
wearing one of the gray short shorts too
yeah it's all the same outfit well this
guy has like when I go to Costco I pick
up a three pack of gray shirts it's my
favorite shirt when you buy three at a
time it's much go a good value man have
aers absolutely your parents are
like we want to see you more often
you're working all the time honey right
we want to see you more often you say
okay I get it I love you you know it's
great to have a home-cooked meal what if
I come to dinner
two two nights a month he's talking
about his wife and I'll never miss it
right I'll make his advice
to everybody out there is
to he's saying you can sometimes offer a
compromise and sometimes that will work
out sometimes you'll offer a
compromise and it won't work out mhm but
we're hoping that in this specific
example of saying okay Mom I'll come
twice a month how's that that she's
going to agree to that and she's going
to say well I'd like I'd prefer two to
zero and so B and so
basically basically you want to apply
this to all your relationships you want
to you know say Hey
listen today you buy
lunch and then someday down the road
I'll probably pay for lunch too now some
they might say okay well that sounds
fine but they also might say no why
don't you just pay for your lunch now
because you owe me money and you have
never paid me
back um are you following me
okay good
anyway listen he's just listening to
music on those airpods dude his
eyes he's just buffering he's buffering
my dude's buffering sure no matter what
no matter how busy I am I'll always make
it for at least two night cut to this
and it's ex and then for them they say
Well we'd really love to see you more
often you go well I could we can
experiment with see how like he's going
to grunt right and you know it's the
same kind of thing and they can say okay
well we we'll be very excited to see you
during that time and we understand you
have other things going on you know it
forces them to treat you like an
adult you know but bro are you not an
adult oh this is amazing
how does only have 100 views know I
found that guy from the video his name
is teacher he's done a bunch of podcast
with him too wait I know this we talked
to this guy this is the uh the professor
who's
a a they got AI on yeah let's see how
that went you know when I went to get my
new uh iPhone it was the first time
after the pandemic that I went okay so
it's called youth's unyielding curiosity
inspires trust and Avi L setting him
apart a so this guy is a a
scientist and a scholar and he's got a
ton of interesting to talk about
let's see how interesting this clip is
he says he's got his first iPhone after
the pandemic went to a public store the
Apple Store I I didn't go until to buy
anything out because everything Fu that
that's what love said it's the teacher
from the video the guy who was making
the rules no the teacher is the
screenshot I sent in the Discord it's
super bizarre just a friend of
his dude I love the world of fitus I'm
living for fidus
world oh I don't know who the this
guy is though I don't want to watch
that um right I need to uh real quick I
need to interject with something here oh
the dishwasher yeah so uh I just checked
it is currently uh it's it's almost 420
bro wait it went up no no I'm saying the
time the time right now is 420 thank you
Zach not fair I want to watch one more
uh so here's the thing what time do you
have to go because the dishwasher is
still saying like an hour uh an hour 20
minutes or something um so we might have
to cancel it early and just see how we
did let's just puts around a little bit
and then we'll we'll call it a day cuz
an hour 20 is ridiculous well my
question is what time do you have to get
out of here I can stay I mean I I prefer
to get home and spend time with the kids
but I can stay longer if we need to
you're raising your kids is more
important than testing dishwashers no
that's not what I said well that's
you're putting words in my mouth kind of
like kind of sounding like that no I'm
saying sometimes it's okay if I stay
late uh you
know it's fine my point just being is
that uh we could potentially hit cancel
on it let it drain and just see no no no
where we're at no we got to do it look
at this do looks affect your career in
the adult industry what the does
that
mean do do no they don't
okay hold on yeah nobody cares about
that actually you think the ls play a
big role in this industry that like the
weirdest dumbest question do you
have to be attractive to be a successful
in a field that
basically chooses People based on how
attractive they are yeah and so I was
saying you know I ask
myself when I look at models I say how
much does looks have to
do with being a model and the
interesting answer is a lot it has a lot
to do with it you
know
[Laughter]
fascinating
uhhuh
did I love him so hold on we got to do
those on Friday when Gabe calls you got
to get fous up there all right let's see
the answer who knows and also generally
in life like do looks matter in life
interesting
question what is he a sociologist
probably you are like do you think life
is easier for
you probably if I'm being honest yeah I
think cuz you're hot as is what
easier it was unclear to me but thanks
for clearing that up they've done
they've done studies and people that are
um like quote objectively Attractive
people are nicer to them they score
better in interviews people are more
patient with them they want to be help
people want to be helpful more to them
so again I didn't just I didn't create
my face or anything I I work out so I
try to stay healthy and fit in that
regard but like this is I was born with
it um out of my control so I think it's
it's very um how do I say very very um
grounded uh response yeah defin very
humble Earth I accept your this like I
was born with this she's pretty how do
you beautiful how do you answer that
question
it's not really her fault yeah right
like that's such an awkward
question yeah definitely helpful but if
you look at the industry there's some
girls that you look at and you're like
they're not necessarily A goodl looking
but they do really well and them she is
not a
girl so we like there are some
in the industry that are busted as
and I would look at them and think not
ever in a million years but they're
making money they're doing it the the
she is a beat
ass you got mileage from don't go out
here calling other girls ugly that is so
un uncool she is not a girls girl what a
jaded response you can call yourself
beautiful don't call other people
ugly yeah name some names let's see how
How brave you are thing about their
presence on camera and the way that they
perform or whatever it is their branding
does really well and then they're very
successful I think that's one of the
interesting things that challenges what
we would say is like stereotypical
Beauty because if you look at you know
the top 50 performers currently there's
like a lot of real ug in there
wait hold on hold on where's she going
with this performers currently there's
like a lot of variety a ton of variety
yeah some are really pretty some are
super
ugly there's a huge variety oh man so I
think a lot of it too is finding that
confidence within yourself and that
confidence is magnetic and people want
some of it because so much of so much of
our life has been LED without that so if
someone has figured it out I want to
follow them and be a part of it too
because then maybe I can figure it
out so hold on hold on hold on let me
Capt because then maybe I can figure it
out so you said it's helps but it's not
a deal
breaker for sure
m
what do you
think I don't no I'm not in the I'm
experiencing the other side of the
spectr
so so I don't think you're by the way
just to glaze him up a little you're not
ugly you're just weird you're right
[Music]
yeah
let's go I think it was a good call yeah
it was safe but there's it's not that
his personality is bad it's that he's
did you guys hear what I said I said
he's not I'm going to glaze him up he's
not ugly at all he's he's he's fine
looking it's just he's weird that's
it I F that's how it
ended I think in the other side of the
spectrum so he wanted her to disagree
so hold on hold on this is
nut can we cut this uh Ian I want to use
this just him when something funny
happens you
know yeah I don't know I'm not in the
I'm experiencing the other side of the
spectum
so
so what what do thatan oh my God this is
the best content
ever holy
smokes I think you're right it's got to
be AI because it makes no sense the cuts
yeah
my god
dude well as you can see AI is doing
really well for
him very
exciting all right well I think it's a
good time
to look at the
thumbnails I think it's a good time to
check on the
dishes okay we're gonna get Tom on the
phone Dan is in the bathroom wait for
him
and then meanwhile there's a clip I
wanted to show you
guys why did there's the clip go look
for the
clip fresh and fit fan okay this is real
interesting you
guys so as far as I can tell this is
like a Adam 22 guy is he a fresh and fit
guy I don't know anything about him I'm
not familiar but I he works at no jumper
it says Instagram okay
cool you better watch out praising me
around
Adam Adam 16 or whatever Adam
IG Adam but anyway listen to
him it's great I had listen like the
last year and a half
yeah I feel like going from like 24 to
25 was like a big jump for me right so
now like I here like here for example I
like went from thinking that like in
h3h3 like Ethan was like the biggest in
the world to now like I hear him
speaking I'm like hey it sounds pretty
rational that's what's up yo first of
all I love him so much and just so
happens that around 25 is when your
brain finishes developing and I don't
say that to be like smug or an I
agree I wasn't fully developed until I
was in my I would say mid to late 20s as
well so you got a beautiful fully
functioning gorgeous frontal cortex loes
uh pumping out electricity and all kinds
of good stuff and you're looking around
and you're seeing you look you see me
and you say now this is a real adult
this is really informed intelligent
stuff that I can get down with not this
he saw the clip of you talking
about flushing a paper towel like this
guy knows I do wonder what clip he
saw you know what I mean it was probably
a debate clip oh debate clip that's true
I assume it got into his feed that's
true that's true that would be
it so that's proof though that the bait
stuff
really works for us it's really good
those do usually go pretty good um so I
had stepped away but am I hearing we're
we're calling it on the dishwasher
should I so how long's it been washing I
mean we started it about 20 minutes into
the show it's 4:30 now so it's been
three over 3 hours uh like 245 it's been
like 2 hours and 45 minutes I that's
originally what we set it to right but
is there is there something that happens
at the end of the wash that is important
not really I mean the rinse I mean it is
still in the wash cycle which likely
means that it's still detecting that the
water is
soiled which isn't a huge surprise
wonder why and uh but it is what it is
you know what I
mean hold on how do
dishwashers detect it just hasn't yet
gotten to the rinse cycle which would be
just like getting all the soap off and
everything what happened should have
happened what should have happened most
dishwashers have inbuilt turbidity
sensors that measures how much dirt is
in the water from the first rinse so
rinsed plates may fool the system it is
what it is
huh turbidity
sensors okay let's call it here's the
alternative we just let it finish no we
got to do and we show the results on
Friday no let's do it no let's do it not
interested yeah I I want it all people
are going to say this ruins the
Integrity of the test it doesn't it's
been going for 3 hours this is
it did it and by the way the what it's
doing now is the intense heat washing
scrubbing phase mhm so it's done that
for three hours mhm if that's
not cleaning these Place nothing
is and that's on
God that's on God uh-huh all right I'm
going to go to the bathroom I'll be
right
back so should I get that going okay
somebody else can can Vamp here Zach do
you have anything to uh plug perhaps any
any surprise shows coming up uh yes
thank you for uh uh saying that uh this
Sunday I'm doing a uh surprise Halloween
show this place called the last call in
Tarzana um Halloween show you going to
do some spooky covers you're going to do
some spooky covers some good times some
good Tunes uh tickets are available only
at the door you got any Misfits songs on
the uh we might have some Misfits we
might have some Boingo we might have a
little
this he's
listening just keep going keep going
don't IGN so
yeah
[Laughter]
dra Dan says that we are draining drain
gang so yeah anyway that's right this
weekend be there last call
Sunday it's going to take a few minutes
to drain it says said 3 minutes so let
it do its thing drain just uh in the dra
the drainer confirmed did we talk about
predictions already like what which ones
we think will I mean we talked about a
little bit as we were going over them
but here let me um let me pull up our
Nifty little chart
[Music]
here there we go um so to just remind
everybody Ethan's plate was covered well
he actually had two he had a peanut
butter plate and a and a goo plate oh my
bad and uh it's fine and um I had the
raisin brand Olivia had the hardened uh
caramelized sugar I guess you would call
it y Zach had the melted cheese cam had
paint Ian had bacon grease Sam had grits
AB had a shitload of oatmeal uh Lena had
eggs on a frying pan and love was the
wild card he had basically five types of
glue paint U plate of death spackle glue
spackle all kinds of stuff um so we'll
see how it goes flavors I
mean I have to say with it ending early
it it's hard to say I mean I I would
predict that the more typical food stuff
I think the Grits it'll do fine the egg
will probably be
fine um The
Oatmeal that's fine I'm worried about
the uh the bacon grease to be honest
that thing really I mean it did you see
it it was like it was thick dude I don't
know I've clean pant and just some hot
water and just go right off in my
opinion okay I mean it might be okay um
the peanut butter I think it get fine
personally um Olivia is
the I wouldn't be surprised if that's
just still completely on there you would
not be surprised just see it was like
hardened epoxy glue I'm excited to see
what happen I sent you a video pulled up
real fast
okay uh here do you want me to send we
just hit our thousandth episode really
aware cuz now that we're doing so
many well we've been doing four shows
for a while
there is the numerics are really uh all
over the place but in terms of uploads I
think we just hit a
thousand yeah I mean there's a handful
of videos on the main channel that
aren't full podcast episodes not a lot
not a lot but so we're probably still a
few off from a thousand in reality but
thousand videos on the channel is pretty
crazy uh somebody just posted this and
so a little reflective thanks for
sticking around and hanging out with us
during this these you know we're we're
still exploring what number episode is
this like 19 18 18 or 19 yeah I mean
it's crazy we've even done that many but
like Joe Rogan just hit a thousand thous
so you know my dream for the show is I
want to be bigger and better we're
always trying to figure out new formats
and stuff so thank you guys for coming
along for the ride that's it dude we
made it to a thousand
crazy who would have who would have
thought this guy was such an idiot back
then I watched this I'm like oh that
was horrible exploring territories
with us I think this show has a lot of
potential I think we're already we're
already there it is so thank you uh for
posting that there we are a
thousand and we've graduated to uh this
kind of tremendous content let's go to
the dishwasher my friends let us see the
results
uh right and we do have um Tom on the
line here so let me uh Tom Ward bring
the illustrious Tom Ward dishwasher
expertone interview extraordinaire is
coming to help commentate there's it
there is Tommy
Boy
hello hey um one second I'm I'm plug and
Ian check
Discord
[Music]
once that Tom we're just set up it looks
like the audio should be connecting now
hello Tom can you hear us hello can you
hear me we sure can welcome back hey now
hey
now okay wait um welcome Tom hold on
we're just we're doing some
uh okay yeah so Tom how you been since
uh the last time we spoke to you
here I've been good Ethan I've been I
feel like a truck has run over my head
why why I'm fighting a cold but you know
what I'm here and why am I here because
I want to get to the end of this debate
and settle it once and for all who we
need to
pre let's get an answer so I don't know
if you watched the beginning but we put
these dishes through the ringer Tom
Thomas if I may we we we cooked
everything thing we get we even put
concrete on some I'm not going to lie to
you uh we we'll going to take them out
one by one based on the likelihood of it
being clean I think is that the right is
that right Dan
uh
yeah sure we can do it that way yes yes
yes yeah I think we have the pyramid set
up uh in that way so let's just get
right into it let's
start uh okay so one sec I I just
realized Tom is covering the pyramid on
my screen here we'll have to go back and
forth that's fine uh do you want to come
Ethan can I make a comment before we
even look at the dishes please sure I am
automatically suspicious right off the
bat of the additional time that was
added to this cycle yeah me too we
didn't finish the cycle it well Dan says
we didn't finish the cycle it kept
adding time I mean what's the deal with
that you know why it did that Ethan
would you like to know why because it
has Auto sensor and it knows their dirty
dishes so adding time but Tom isn't that
in favor of the theory that it can clean
the dishes because it knows if they're
dirty or not that correct but how long
do we have I mean I don't have 14 hours
to get clean dishes no no and who does
who does no one does nobody has that
time well let's start looking at them we
did we did ended up doing 245 which is
about what it said it would take so so
we're we're pretty much
on on the expected uh duration
there Tom you say you're feeling sick
but you look
fantastic hey it's all for you guys for
H3 I bring my a game
absolutely okay so we are walking into
the kitchen the big reveal is happening
my friends no we have done our very very
best to stump the dishwasher
and finally
today we will
see okay here we go are you ready for
the
reveal okay what's
first let's take a
look so that I can't see hold on hold I
can't see it's ugly
oh oh how did I
sh
someone said 245 is mad long for one
dishwasher that's what it said to do
should I should I drag him off that was
the initial estimate
and
um you can just minimize his camera
we'll hear him I don't know all right
Dan can you just help love to uh all
right do
that all right dishwashers I haven't
seen the dish so I don't even know what
I'm dealing
[Music]
with all
right you guys
St pull them out one by one a
trick
[Music]
yeah all right what do we got first okay
let's pull out Olivia first cuz oh my I
can tell dude there is nothing that was
vile oh my God it fell out
wait what happened the Whisk it detached
is it just covered in so it has Suds on
it because it didn't finish the cycle
Rin so why don't we just rinse it off
and see how it looks after you rinse it
off yeah just give it a little Rin off
we need a post rinse to prevent
pre-rinse uh so far it's not looking too
promising oh okay that is not rinsing
off all right now let's get a close up
so which pan was this what was this
covered so this was covered in the uh
caramelized corn syrup essentially hold
that up please to the camera so we can
get a nice closeup exhibit a I can't see
it
youing
this that thing is
dirty holy
now that's surprising me how hard
is that take a take try to Nick that off
with your nail e and that's just like
the sugar caramelized sugar right ew it
couldn't get that
off yeah that's not looking good now
taste
it don't don't please please please
please don't don't don't don't okay okay
so well we can go to the pyramid and say
that the caramelized plate is certainly
that's going to need another wash
absolutely absolutely that
is that thing is not done wait okay okay
I'm not feeling too hopeful about this
I'm feeling great uh let's look at the
eggs which Lena did all right
uh that is not good those eggshells that
is not good got some of them off but
some is not what we're looking for you
cook with that is that good enough no
hell no good point Tom good point hold
on hold on hold on is this just a bad
washing machine I think we oh my God it
we needed to have let it finish I think
pulling it early is totally corrupted
dude it was three hours yeah but
the machine knew that it needed more
time I that kind of time Dan I mean he's
running the show here come on I mean I
agree we we had to wrap it up so I mean
we're doing it but I I just don't know I
don't know what this proves
necessarily proves in three
hours is not getting these dishing I
just noticed something uh if you could
show the inside of that Lena oh my
goodness
e that is so gross no wonder it
thought it was dirty yeah it seems like
it is a little dirty holy dude e e
Cameron
please that's like all oatmeal is it
oatmeal and grits and concrete it's a
you think it's a
mix Olivia is going to throw up right
now what's it smell like Olivia please
don't throw up if I have a phobia ew
Cameron why do you why are you
comfortable touching that stuff wait
what what am I doing oh that's not you
who is that it's AB Oh I thought it was
Cameron AB stop it's gross I got clean
hands smell it how's it
smell smells like soio okay okay that's
not bad that's fair that's fair no I on
a real though AB I really appreciate you
getting in there and showing us that
that that's Brave yeah no that's
necessary oh yeah no I used to work at a
doctor's office I put my hands in a lot
worse very good all right what's
next it's Ian's or Sam's so that's Ian's
and that was the Bacon Fat I gotta say
that looks pretty good that is clean can
you uh give it another little rinse
there okay uh just to see if if the rest
of that will fall off I think those are
just that's the pattern of the pan I
think it just has white
specks nah oh so what are the white
specks yeah so something's stuck on
there I mean it could be the Gorilla
Glue it could be the uh it could be
could be it could be the plaster all
right so AB tell us what are you
seeing some white stuff stuck to it does
it feel oily it does it does feel like
it's yeah a little greasy still it with
37 ft of cement man I I actually thought
that one would be so we calling that one
uh clean enough I think everything is so
far no absolutely not need another yeah
the eggs the eggs needed another wash no
not call Bacon needs another wash too
not call
clean enough no no dude hand
cleaned some extras I think hand cleaned
some extras on that one hell no that
thing was dirty it had am I am I crazy
does anyone agree I agree it's got
dollops of grease on it okay all right
needs another wash it's covered in
it all right well let's keep it rolling
all right here's the
oatmeal all looks like right God
yeah that thing is dirty man as
predicted mhm is there any oatmeal left
or is that just on the bottom there's
enough in here for another plate in the
gross yeah there's oatmeal on the bottom
love it's caked on there yeah o is that
glue that's
oatmeal why is there oatmeal on the
bottom there wasn't when we started
that's what I'm saying it's just flung
up get flung all over how do you get
oatmeal on the bottom yeah I don't know
how we how did we get
oatmeal uh this Cam's he there we go
that's something oh wow no okay well
yeah it's coded wait it's covered in
from other place
right yeah that was the pain this is
like Monumental
disaster we didn't I I don't know I
don't think this is a a fair analysis I
mean I think I think be right about that
hold on M we filled the dishwasher with
a bunch of dirty dishes mhm that's what
you're supposed to do but you're
supposed to do a whole cycle we didn't
do the time was not in the conversation
I can't help but agree man stop stop how
much was stuck at the bottom not
only is it not clean a lot of that
is dirtier but it was still saying it
needed an hour to go too it needed dude
it's literally covered it it went in
look at this that was just Flo
around that oh that's the paint That's
all the paint I don't know how you do
that a lot of people are saying that I
it up I'm not seeing no that that
looks like oatmeal and pain on that all
right well let's pull loves then and see
how yeah I want to see cuz let's let's
real quick let's let's rank cam here
it's not
clean although clean some extras I'll
say I think it was everyone else's
that made it dirty right but still I
would not I wouldn't be comfortable
using that I would need to wash maybe
but but with the hand clean some extras
you'd be comfortable if you if you just
kind of wiped off or you could have just
pre-rinsed it and Save
right I mean Tom's got a all right fine
needs a wash fine all right let's do
Love's next cuz I'd be willing to bet
that all the glue is on there still
right surely well we're going to find
out right now hold on Tom what are you
what are your feelings so far if I can
ask I'm feeling very smug right now
that's how I feel I predicted this I
knew it was gonna happen um you got a
pre-rinse I mean this proves it beyond a
shadow of a doubt what do you say to the
charges that this isn't a fair test the
the the listen you're running a podcast
okay we don't have 14 hours to wait for
this thing to get them completely clean
we're we're not running a podcast we're
running a scientific experiment this
this is a corrupting the data right now
okay that's fair no but Tom has a point
how long you let her run for you going
to
run however long it takes baby going to
keep going and going and going you guys
want to look at the filter
no oh I'm going to die yeah oh okay show
it all right hold on so Tom is feeling
smug he's feeling like a winner
[Music]
[Applause]
e dude that is so wrong that is so wrong
get it off the screen I'm literally
nauseous
really great great segment though that
is thanks D all right let's look at
Love's PL
take look all
this so what do you see there
interesting there's a lot mixed results
it looks like everything's still on
there
no uh whatever this is still on there
okay that's that's that's the glue these
are empty those two look empty right
three this has this had only these two
yeah those those two seem to have come
off that's toothpaste and uh spackle
toothpaste oh the Spackle came uple is
probably not good dude the lipstick is
fully on there still though interesting
lipsti bad boy don't so the I mean the
Spackle could certainly cause some
problems down there I I'd imagine so
yeah I'd imagine so think
so all right so we have the tape lasted
that's some good tape
yeah walls right oh yeah seal them hide
probably not good to use an industrial
sealant no no no in a washing machine
here's some of this stuff from the
bottom
oh hold
on that is so dinner served like
egg without a doubt probably some cheese
in there some paint not not not only am
I convinced that you must pre-wash I'm
convinced that I don't think I ever want
to use a dishwasher again I think
they're disgusting I've actually turned
you away from dishwasher wow all right
what's next disas wait real quick real
quick so love I mean mean I mean we
could probably with a little hand
cleaning I mean clean enough yeah all
right fine needs another watch needs to
be thrown out I think we need another
category
wow all right let's take a look at uh oh
that's mine hey W okay what is what was
that no problem that was raisin brand
okay the bottom little gross but I'm
not that's I eat from the bowl
that's a dub not the bottom the ball I
think we can say and I I think we can
say it's clean like clean enough I think
so even though the Bottom's disgusting I
blame that on the the other stuff yeah
it's a lot of to Earth
c big dub clean clean clean clean all
right keep it rolling uh how about
Zach's or okay go ahead with that one e
dude what the um so that was the
Grits yeah again the inside is kind of
clean but the outside is just thrashed
with disgusting dishwasher right
rub rub your uh thumb over those that
residue AB how how easily does that fall
off is it still stuck on there it's
coming off that looks like it comes off
I would say you could hand clean that
and you'd be okay to use it no
look how easily that's coming off I
dude no that was concrete when it
went in that is being that must be
cleaned again you're going to take a
towel and and just look at that come on
you got to clean that again you got to
clean that it's definitely a lot tougher
than the
inside please rinse your hand B I'm
dying I'm dying it's literally pain to
see my body is just full convulsing in
revulsion clean all right so uh Sam's
grits we're we're saying that needs
another
wash disappointing man this is brutal
that had the square circle plate I the
uh Circle plate yeah so that's the
cheese that's Zach oh that's good that
looks Okay upon closer
inspection it's clean enough I'd say
there's no she on there left yeah that's
again it's no no there's some there is
there it's like actually really I
wouldn't eat off that no I'm going
to eat off any of this what if you hand
clean the little bit but here's the
thing everything has been like infected
because there's so much
organisms and bacteria that's in that
dishwasher right now that you
you just going to have to throw
everything out I think I would actually
like to make a point about that so if we
gave additional time would they be clean
no maybe I don't because that that
filter is so clogged that it's gonna be
dirty floating around all over your
dishes it will never be clean Tom for
exactly the reason you said the filter
is clogged it's keeping the filth in the
washing machine right is that what the
dishwasher is supposed to do hell no
exactly Tom how long how long were you
in the business for 10 years W so he
knows what the he's talking about
that's that's experience I'm curious if
Tom thinks the concrete ruined it or if
this is just like regular like the
oatmeal and would have ruined it on
stand alone that makes sense you guys
really legit put concrete in oh yeah
it's not concrete not concrete it was
concrete it was rubber cement and uh and
uh spackle spackle it could yeah maybe
cuz it's like a mesh screen so maybe it
like CL the holes the Spackle was
probably too
far that being said I mean the egg
wasn't going down those tiny little mesh
you know but did the Spackle clog that
mesh and that's why the there was there
was would have gone through already
right yeah I mean there was a lot of
oatmeal in there it looks like there was
some paint and some other stuff in the
filter let's keep going that's going to
be a start of Co why are comfortable
touching that stuff he loves it I mean
it's sanitary I know oh it is this is
just like this is just like playing with
slime for me right yeah oh God all right
what's next I can't I can't do it yeah
what's next what's next all right so
Zach that was this so Zach Zach we were
saying uh needs another wash huh not
even hand in the trash everything trash
dude that is vile what is this I
don't know what uh wasn't that one yours
yeah that was one of yours is there
peanut butter on it or is it other
yeah there's there's a residue from
peanut butter wait are you sure that's
not the goo uh plate there were two
there was a goo plate and a peanut
butter that's the peanut butter I'm not
exactly sure but I am sure that every
plate is so I don't know right
that's the peanut butter
one and then the the spatula one side
had slime one side had peanut butter
that is disgusting I don't see any green
slime to be honest wait the Slime
actually one came off yeah
huh so we're calling that clean enough
yeah and then there's one more plate
that I put slime
on the dishwasher is so
it must be oh it was this one I
think it's that one I I put the residue
on there so here's what I here's what
I'm saying I'm saying we need to remove
the dishwasher with all that in it
and throw it in a
dumpster agreed just just wholesale just
remove the whole dishwasher it's all
it's cursed to go
it we can't recover this thatal failure
this is a
failure Tom do you want to take rout is
there anything you want to say to Dan in
closing Dan you made some excellent
points and you know what I appreciate
most Dan is you took the assignment
seriously thank you thank you this was
no joke this was no silly argument you
really put your heart and soul into it
and it showed it showed you care and
that's
important
so true you know this is real world
stuff it affects everybody watching not
just us this has real you know lasting
effects one thing I will also want to
say I do want to pull the audience here
was this a fair
test well I think okay I'll and when I
say and listen to me when I say
fair I mean
like like ignoring the speckle
concrete I feel like if just use your
mind and think like if you're looking at
a plate with peanut butter on it there's
still a little peanut butter on it Let's
ignore the oatmeal and all the and all
the disgusting caked on the back
just genuinely is this a good
representation of if you can preash or
not okay do you that's pretty long can I
so here let's see can you pre do do do
like
this must must you pre-wash yes or no
must you pre-wash let's see if the
needles
mov or
no lots of people are saying the test
was bad not a fair test I mean guys all
right starting the poll must you
pre-wash yes or
no I
mean wait what you guys under okay hold
on it's still going
votes are rolling in here how are people
still saying no I guess these are people
who are they call them Dum they're
protesting the test itself probably big
massive dumps people are saying bad poll
Ethan must you
pre-wash I think they're idiots Ethan
that's what I think they can't they
can't be be
sence Tom's words I love all of you oh
regardless of IQ and mental aptitude wow
we love all of our all folks watching
I'm I'm saying a lot love3 peace and
love I say that peace and of course we
love you you're very special well I
don't know are they saying that we need
to redo this without speckle and
industrial strength concrete and paint
and lead and are we going to buy any
dishwasher there but yeah I don't know I
mean I'm going to have to take a look
once we go up the air at this dishwasher
situation but I have a feeling we're
going to we're going to need a new one
on your own there buddy a huge deal we
just we were shopping earlier we
actually going to have to change it
that's up I mean I don't know yet
I'll have
toam probably I think the speckle
speckle is not that much it was like
literally this small of a pizza slice I
don't there's more other stuff there's
more to it I mean it's possible and it's
so fine it's going to dissolve fully and
go through the I I think we we made it a
point to make the dish as Mo up
as possible with the most amount of
so I I think it average day when you
know you're washing dishes you're eating
food you're not always going to have
that much on there sure so I feel
that creates a new element to why the
dishwasher broke so you're saying a
better test would be some regular dishes
that are regular dirty and then maybe
one or two super I think that
would be more of a fair uh fun cuz we
put like a whole refrigerator of
that's what I'm saying right I think we
need to let it run in its entirety too
was never going to finish I how do you
know the filter was blocked we didn't do
it the filter was blocked how do we how
do we know here's what's going to happen
midnight we still be waiting Tom I love
you I love you Tom but just cuz you look
like Mr Clean doesn't make it him
okay but cam it's blocked you can't you
can't I believe I believe in taking it
to its final finality uh and I don't
think I would have liked to have seen
that I don't necessarily disagree with
you Ethan um even as the advocate for
the no pre-rinse that um it would have
made much of a difference because as you
pointed out the uh entire bottom of the
dishwasher being completely full of
oatmeal probably wouldn't have changed
in the next hour so I was surprised by
how fine the mesh was it looked like a
coffee holder yeah a coffee filter kind
which doesn't make any sense because of
course you're going to have oatmeal
specs of oatmeal and food in your wash
even if you pre-wash what what's going
to happen next is going to get flooded
with water uh in the drain area and
that's just going to keep happening and
happening and happening so it's kind of
like it's I think it I think
you're probably going to want to
pre-wash something that's really
dirty I never contended that you should
never pre-wash oh you're taking it back
no no no if you go check the transcript
you were a religious check the
transcript no I said I was washer you
still need to soak certain things you
are on your knees praying to the washing
Gods thanking them for your salvation
you need to go check the tapes all right
you're a washer org now huh well there
it is guys at long last the great
question I believe has been answered
perhaps our methodology was flawed in in
some spots but I do feel that
holistically we can look at these
results and take some meaning from it
that meaning is what
Tom pre-wash your damn dishes
wow all right me give it up in the book
of in the book of cascade 3:16 Thou
shalt pre-wash the dish
exactly now I do think there's
flexibility like you can put like a kind
of dirty one in there but I think if
it's like up dirty that ain't
going to work pre rinse that thing yeah
pre-rinse that prein I think that's fair
I think that's fair run it back people
are saying n I'm done I think I think
we've talked enough about dishwashers
yeah yeah exhausted this a little bit
you know short starting a podcast
dedicated to
dishwashers I think we've expired uh our
welcome but thank you everybody well
played thank you Tom thank you Tom
pleasure thank you guys it was a
pleasure Dan your gentlemen everyone
well Tom guys are amazing everybody
subscribe and watch my channel the Tom W
show new interviews every Wednesday and
live thday Ian what about the thing oh
he's been doing it
oh I didn't see it yeah okay okay okay
thank you Tom yeah uh everybody you know
go watch Tom Ward interview
extraordinaire the man is talking to all
the people that matter and he's asking
him the questions that matter right Tom
and we're doing Goblin mode as well you
know I'm doing Sam and Kobe next Friday
you know those guys that's the the
the prank remember my best friend get oh
S kby I do know who they are I'm doing
them next Friday and they hit me up they
stayed at the house The Conjuring was
filmed in which is first of all is
insane what you say but they said it was
like a lifechanging experience and I
want to see like is this or is
this real wait what was life changing
they stay they said like being there
they had like an experience with The
Conjuring house the house from the it's
been trending I think it's got 10
million views in like two days oh
they're phonies dude come on they
they're they're like they're like fake
prankers but don't say anything we love
them I don't want to it up for you
no
time get real answers I'm pretty sure
the the kidnapping prank they weren't in
on that they were the ones being pranked
and it was like you going how you going
to pretend you're dead and not be in on
the prank oh one of them was pranked one
of them I remember it was like traumatic
I think it was all I think it was all
faked it's Sam Pepper for Christ's sake
Peppa the crying was
scary Peppa all right Tom we love you
thanks Tom guys we love you thank you
for having me it's an honor to be back
all right we'll talk to you soon peace
and love peace and love to all everybody
out there this is a serious message Tom
Ward
everybody well I got to say I my
expectation is that it would be cleaner
frankly yeah no I mean that was shocking
but I guess we'll just nightm never know
what that extra hour would have done it
is a nightmare we'll just never know I
was joking hold on I was joking that
because this is an unreleased song of
Dreams that we can actually make it and
then copyright it and then when he tries
to release his song we can sue
him but and so Zach play the whole song
somebody did
[Music]
it
wait this is the H3 podcast original
track wait
dude how trippy is this for Dream It's
like
[Music]
triumphant like
that I will say I discovered it sounds
better when you drop it like a
semitone you're are you playing it that
way I got to give a big up no this is uh
normal you guys want me to show you the
dream dance pop
rock I got to give a big UPS to whoever
made that Zach did it uh it's in the
dock it's
uh it is uh uh six under top of show oh
someone made a full dream so uh version
yeah so we're GNA we're going to
copyright that and
frankly I hope that I hope that he's not
planning on dropping that song now
because frankly it would be uh
infringing on my rights while we wait
for dream to drop the full version I
give you this a
nightmare from Jake Cronin 343 Dre
Cronin it actually is pretty lit as they
would
[Applause]
[Music]
say the metan of this song like we can
now play this at our live shows play
this when we go out and it sounds like a
song I think we should start and end the
show with it uh every episode like what
is dream going to think about it it's so
funny and it it's just doesn't sound
like a joke so anyone who hears it will
just think it's a normal song but it is
a
joke but it's also a good
song well guys that's
it thank you
everybody when you're not there not
there not there
[Music]
you're you're
there
[Music]
you're well guys thanks for watching
everybody this is HG podcast Wednesday's
episode there's no leftovers tomorrow
the show's on pause for now um but we
will be back on Friday with a terrific
fun exciting
episode for everybody to
enjoy and uh oh po Poké Mame will be
here on Friday and we'll be doing
um we'll be doing kind of like a a
normal episode plus Pokemon man friend
show drops in to say hi kind of thing
you know what I mean it should be fun
yeah it'll be a good
time uh all right
[Music]
everybody you're not there you're not
there all right we can just we can play
us out Zach go ahead thanks everybody
we'll see you on
Friday
so there my head goes
Hearts like I can't
when here see tonight man
nightm nightm I can't
feel there not there my head goes my
heart beats fast it feels
[Music]
like